Yan Artus Bertrand, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Yan Artus Bertand, 74 ans, photographe.
On vous savez, on vous a on vous a fait
venir ce soir pour parler d'écologie,
parler de votre dernier film Legacy,
pour parler de perspective et de
prospective et même peut-être un peu de
futur. Comment est-ce que vous voyez
notre futur ? J'en sais rien. Je suis
pas futurologue.
Il y a des gens qui font beaucoup mieux
que moi. Et c'est d'ailleurs c'est c'est
drôle parce que quand on avait commencé
le dans Legacy, on est les on commence
par la grotte chauvon
voit ces gens qui la avec des comment
c'était magnifique l'histoire. C'était
magnifique. Oui. Et ces images 3D images
3D et on voit imagine ces types qui avec
des avec de la graisse d'animaux, tu
vois, dans la fumée dessin ces dessins
qui ont 35000 ans. C'est extraordinaire.
Et ces types, ils savaient pas d'où il
venaient et ils savaient pas où ils
allaient.
Et voilà, il vivent dans un monde assez
hostile, même sauvage. Alors que nous,
on sait très bien d'où on vient et on
sait très bien où on va. Et ça qui a été
intéressant, ce que je voulais dire dans
le film, enfin on l'a pas dit parce
qu'on a dit autre chose, mais ça va
toujours fasciner euh euh l'intelligence
de l'homme quoi. Cette capacité
incroyable qu'ils ont eu euh alors un
animal qui était pas du tout doué, qui
était qui avait pas de de griffe, qui
avait pas une une peau solide, ben qui
ont réussi à à coloniser le monde
uniquement par l'entraide et
l'intelligence. Voilà. Et c'est ça
l'histoire de l'égacy et aussi de
commencer par cette histoire incroyable
de l'homme sur la terre. Ça m'a toujours
fasciné que ce qu'on a réussi à faire
quoi. Comment aujourd'hui l'homme a
réussi à coloniser la terre et
pratiquement supprimer tout ce qu'il y a
pas tout ce qu' a plus pas humain sur la
terre n'existe plus quoi. On est
vraiment il y a plus que l'homme
aujourd'hui.
Alors l'homme sait où il va. Alors il va
où ? [rires]
Mais il va vers un monde compliqué. Si
on on croit ce que que dis ce que disent
les scientifiques. On va voir un il y a
pas très longtemps. Il y avait un
article il y a quelques jours sur le sur
la météo en France par exemple. Mét
France.
Oui, de météo France. C'est quand même
incroyable. C'est c'est épouvantable ce
qu'il raconte. Il raconte que à la fin
du siècle, si on continue comme ça, il y
aura 4 à 6 degrés. Et 4 à 6 degrés de
différence sur en France, bah c'est des
problèmes d'alimentation, c'est des
problèmes, on a même pas idée où où on
va avec ça. Voilà.
Vous côtoyez souvent des puissants ou
vous êtes invité souvent par des
puissants ?
Pas tant que ça. Pas tant que ça.
Pas tant que ça. Les politiques
peut-être vous consultent.
Pas vraiment. Pas vraiment. Je je je
connais beaucoup de politiques avec qui
euh je parle. Non, je ne
suis pas il consulte pas. Je crois qu'on
regarde mes films où on écoute les ce
que les ce qu'on ce qu'on dit à la
fondation. Mais je pense pas qu'on me
consulte beaucoup. Non.
Les politiques avec qui vous discutez,
il ils ont quel constat ?
Mais je pense que l'homme politique
aujourd'hui euh alors d'abord les gens
que j'ai vu autour de moi qui
s'intéresse le plus à l'écologie, c'est
souvent des politiques femmes.
Idalgo par exemple, que ce soit Valérie
PCR que je connais un petit peu,
je les ai vu écouter des conférences
longtemps sont pianoté sur leur portable
en s'intéressant vraiment à ce qui se
passait et c'est pas étonnant d'ailleurs
que on s que les les les grandes
héroïnes de l'environnement c'est des
femmes. Et pourquoi ? Parce qu'il y a un
intérêt pour l'avenir. Je sais pas, j'ai
toujours été étonné. En tout cas, ces
deux femmes-là que je connais un tout
petit peu s'intéressent à l'écologie et
j'ai vu par exemple Valérie PCR écouter
une conférence sur le changement
climatique à la fondation pendant 1
heure en prenant des notes et en se
concentrant. Voilà, ça m'a assez
impressionné
et je d'ur je je dis pour pour rigoler,
je disais que pour la prochaine
élection présidentielle, j'aurais bien
vu un ticket PCR Sidalgo. Voilà,
j'aurais bien vu ensemble. Alors, c'est
pas possible mais j'aurais bien vu deux
femmes intelligentes ayant l'habitude de
qui en dirigé des territoires importants
capable de diriger la France.
Vous votez ?
Ouais, bien sûr, je vote. C'est
important de voter. J'ai toujours voté
vert d'ailleurs depuis toujours. Sans
doute peut-être plus par romantisque,
par efficacité, mais je vote du monde.
J'ai voté du monde années 70. Donc tu
vois, c'est pas d'aujourd'hui à l'époque
où l'écologie n'existait pas quoi.
L'écologie c'est pas c'était plus parler
de jardinage quelque part. Je me
souviens dans le petit village où
j'habitais,
je je je voyais ma voix dans le journal.
Il y avait une voix du mon c'était la
mienne. 3 400 voix.
Quelle est votre votre perception des
des partis écologistes en France ?
C'est une querelle de clocher. C'est
c'est de l'opportunisme politique. C'est
quoi ?
Je les connais très peu en fin de compte
parce que moi je en fin de compte ce
monde politique, je me sens pas à l'aise
du tout avec eux. Euh j'ai toujours voté
vert, ça m'intéresse. Euh
euh
le le c'était c'était Gemar ou Recard
qui m'avait dit ça qu'on avait fait en
interroger pour Yuman, qui disait que la
méchanceté était une qualité en
politique et malheureusement je pense
que c'est il y a du vrai là-dedans et je
vois chez les verts c'est même
incroyable depuis
en fin de compte je pas je l'ai dit
tellement souvent mais ça m'a toujours
déçu ce voilà c'est ces bagarres
internes qui sont qui devraient pas
avoir lieu et d'ailleurs c'est en train
de changer Ça aujourd'hui il y a une
espèce on c'est drôle parce que moi j'ai
je parlais souvent de bienveillance de
gentillesse et aujourd'hui les même les
politique disent ces mots gentillesse et
bienveillance peut-être que c'est voilà
qu'on en a plus envie
là avec le covid le le pays est
pratiquement arrêté vous avec vos 75
ans, ça vous fait quoi ? Comment vous
percevez ce séisme ? Est-ce que vous y
alors qu'on parlait de pandémie quand
même depuis longtemps et que on était au
courant,
je je pense qu'il faut faire le deuil du
monde d'avant qui le monde d'avant ne
reviendra jamais parce que ça nous a
permis de réfléchir, de de voyager d'une
façon différente, de communiquer les
visoconférences, le la cette vision de
de faire peut-être plus attention à
l'autre, de se rapprocher. Moi, j'ai eu
la chance de faire un
confinement chez moi à la campagne et je
me suis beaucoup promené dans la forêt,
énormément. Et je je peux te demander un
truc en direct, c'est J'aimerais j'aim
bien que tu me regardes quand je parle
parce que
Non non que je vois je te regarder tes
trucs. C'est pas c'est ça c'est Je te
dis gentiment, je pas je pas j'aime bien
parler à quelqu'un.
Je t'explique là en ce moment tu es en
train de parler à moi. Tu es surtout en
train de parler à toute la communauté
qui est qui est ploguée avec mon écran à
droite. D'accord. Et en fait, je vois
notre communauté interagir en direct.
Mais ce n'est pas un manque de respect.
Non, c'est pas un manque de respect.
C'est que c'est bon, c'est pas grave.
Et et c'est important pour nous,
j'aime bien parler à toi. Voilà.
D'accord.
Je me ferai un grand plaisir de te
montrer sur le chat. D'accord.
On reprend. Je suis désolé.
Non, mais toujours pas désolé, je te le
disais avec je je bienveillance hein.
Euh et quand j'étais dans dans ma voilà,
là on est bien, on se regarde dans les
yeux. Quand j'étais chez je me suis
beaucoup promené dehors pendant la
pandémie. dans la forêt et je me suis
interdit hein.
Comment
c'était interdit ?
Euh oui, non mais j'étais resté 1 km de
chez moi mais un peu plus loin et il y
avait personne dans la forêt. Et en fin
de compte, j'ai pris conscience, ce qui
est assez étonnant de la de la beauté de
la forêt alors que moi mon métier était
d'aller photographier les plus beaux
endroits du monde. Il m'apercevait que
la beauté évidente, elle était à côté de
chez moi tout simplement et que j'ai
vécu pendant pendant 2 mois. et tous les
jours dans la forêt, j'ai vu la le
printemps [raclement de gorge] arriver,
j'ai vu les animaux sortir et et c'était
vraiment cette harmonie qu'il y avait
dans la forêt était magnifique mais
vraiment. Et et quand je suis rentré
chez moi après quand au bureau en
Boulogne, je trouvais toutes je trouvais
les villes moches. Je trouvais que les
rues étaient moches, les magasins
étaient moches, quoi. Cette beauté
évidente, ces beauté de la vie
naturelle, harmonie cette harmonie
incroyable. Elle était dans la forêt
autour de chez moi et c'est drôle que
j'arrive à 7 74 ans pour me rendre
compte que cette beauté évidente, elle
était chez moi autour. J'ai passé ma vie
à le chercher, pas ailleurs mais enfin,
elle était là aussi et ça m'a
impressionné. Alors bien sûr
je pense que la crise économique qui va
qui va devant nous va être terrible,
compliqué et que ça va être difficile à
gérer. Voilà, je suis comme tout le
monde, je fais du film, je fais de la
production, tout est arrêté, on peut
plus tourner, on est en train de faire
un film sur les par exemple sur les 150
de la convention citoyenne et que c'est
très difficile de filmer les gens avec
les masques. Donc on a dit qu'on allait
qu'on allait pas continuer. Donc on
attend que que parce que ce qui a ce qui
est formidable la convention citoyenne
et qui m'a sidéré qui m'a vachement
intéressé c'est que tous ces 150
français qui ne qui ne connaissaient
rien à l'écologie choisis un peu par
hasard sont devenus encore plus radicaux
que moi je je suis et ça m'a fasciné
comme ils parlent auprès de leurs amis
auprès de la les gens de leur famille
comme ils sont convaincus maintenant de
leur responsabilité
de citoyen et de choses qu'ils ont
appris pendant ces sep weekends. Et je
pense qu'on devrait tous avoir cette
espèce de formation sur l'environnement,
l'écologie et si les politiques
l'avaient, je pense que sans doute qu'il
se sentirait peut-être un peu plus
concernés. Je je j'imagine.
Est-ce que tu les Est-ce que vous les
sentez coincés les politiques ? C'estàd
qu'ils sont peut-être concernés mais ils
sont coincés. Leur marge de manœuvre
est-elle aussi épaisse qu'une feuille ?
Moi, j'ai une vision de c'est je passe
mon temps dans toutes mes mes
conférences quand j'en fais après le
film. Il faut monter le film en
politique et les lobby et Trump et le
Brésil et les Chinois quoi. C'est c'est
toujours la faute des autres.
Aujourd'hui, je pense sincèrement que
l'homme politique est le reflet de de
notre société. Ils ont été élus. Il nous
ressemble en fin de compte. Quand il y a
la marche pour le climat, on est 50000
dans dans Paris. On est content d'être
50000. Quand il y a l'arrivée de la
coupe du monde, on est 3 millions dans
la rue. Je pense quand on sera 3
millions dans la rue à à manifester
contre le dérèglement climatique, bah
les politiques seront avec nous.
Aujourd'hui, je crois qu'on parle
beaucoup d'environnement, beaucoup
d'écologie, mais on n pas encore on
n'est pas prêt à accepter des
contraintes, on n'est pas prêt
véritablement à faire des efforts. Très
peu de gens le sont parce que on vit
tous de la croissance. On vit de la
croissance. C'est la croissance qui euh
qui paye les hôpitaux, qui paye les
écoles, qui paye les fonctionnaires
et on a besoin de ça pour vivre quoi. Et
donc le le discours des écolo, de vivre
mieux avec moins, de dépenser moins de
pétrole, bah c'est c'est le mot
épouvantable que tout le monde déteste,
ce mot de décroissance quoi. C'est la
c'est presque un mot mal élevé qu'on a
pas le droit de dire, de
post-croissance. Il fall bien falloir
qu'on s'y habitue obligatoirement et
personne n' envie de c'est difficile
mais moi le premier hein je je voilà
dans ma fondation je vis avec des mé
tous imbriqués un peu là-dedans c'est
difficile de changer. Euh voilà et je
pense que l'homme politique est le
reflet de cette angoisse. Et pourquoi
l'homme politique il a été élu ? Il a
été élu pour préserver l'emploi, le
pouvoir d'achat, le point de croissance,
le grad absolu de tout homme politique.
Et le point de croissance n'est pas bon
du tout pour l'environnement. On le sait
tous. Voilà.
On s'est toujours sorti d'une d'une
récession par une augmentation de
consommation énergétique.
Là, on est dans une grosse grosse
récession.
H
on va pas pouvoir faire comme on a fait
depuis les 100 dernières années.
Vous voyez comment le peuple
appréhendait la transition écologique
alors que les gens ont du mal à
travailler, ont du mal à s'alimenter,
ont du mal à trouver du travail.
Mais je te pose des questions
impossibles là que personne ne connaît
la réponse à ça. Ça fait un quel moment
qu'on en parle et je suis pas capable de
répondre à cette question. Je sais
simplement que moi mon travail c'est
d'essayer de d'amener la conscience
psychologique au cœur quoi. Qu' faitin
que de qu'en permanence on soit qu'on
réfléchisse voilà comment
dans ma vie au quotidien je peux je peux
donner du sens à ma vie. Et ce qui est
intéressant aujourd'hui, c'est
cette époque actuelle nous permet à tous
donner du sens à notre vie plus
facilement qu'avant. Je pense qu'en tout
cas c'est une réflexion, on peut tout
savoir et donner sens à sa vie.
Qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
améliorer le monde dans mes dans ma vie
quotidienne et qu'on soit journaliste
comme toi ou qu'on soit
journaliste
non que soit bon pas journaliste que
soit pasiste comme toi que soit [rires]
voilà ou qu'on soit photographe ou
réalisateur comme moi ou qu'on soit
chauffeur de taxi ou architecte ou
chacun a le pouvoir de changer le monde
autour de lui et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on qu'on doit accepter tout ce qu'on
a on peut le faire et voilà et qu'on a
tous le pouvoir de changer le monde à sa
façon et c'est même un devoir et je
pense que on peut tous le faire avec
notre nos nos votes, ce qu'on achète, ce
qu'on fait. Voilà. Et réussir sa vie
professionnel, c'est pas très difficile,
mais réussir sa vie d'homme, c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué.
C'est difficile quand même en ce moment
de réussir sa vie professionnelle.
Je dépend mais Oui, bien sûr. Bien
évidemment, quand on
est jeune, quand on est jeune, quand on
a 20 ans,
quand quand on a déjà du mal à
s'alimenter, quand on se fait expulser
de sa chambre d'étudiant,
alors euh on vit en France.
Mais en France,
en France, moi je m'occupe d'un orfelina
Brasille. C'est pas pas la même chose
hein. Quand vous êtes en France, on est
comme un pays, même s'il y a des gens
qui ont pas les moyens, on a quand même
on est quand même une chance incroyable
dans ce pays avec une éducation
gratuite, avec la santé gratuite.
Quand vous habitez euh à Brazaville et
que vous saabz dans des pays où il y a
pas de travail, où il y a pas de service
de santé, où il y a pas d'éducation, il
y a pas de démocratie, bah vous avez
qu'un rêve, c'est de vivre, d'aller
rejoindre ce pays incroyable. On se on n
jamais content, on se plaint tout le
temps. N'empêche qu'on vit dans un
paradis pour ces gens-là et on a
tendance à l'oublier. Je suis un
privilégié, je le sais. Il y a des gens
qui souffrent beaucoup plus que moi,
mais dans mes voyages, il en vu pas mal
de gens et surtout m'occupe point
d'association et des gens qu'on a
vraiment besoin. On est quand même dans
un pays assez protégé et même
aujourd'hui euh c'est difficile de de se
projeter, mais ça a toujours été
difficile de se projeter qu'on a 20 ans,
qu'on le monde est devant nous,
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ? Et puis
aujourd'hui peut-être aussi c'est plus
compliqué parce que
cette pandémie peut-être nous a fait
réfléchir est-ce que quel métier je vais
faire quoi est-ce que je vais C'est
important d'aimer ce qu'on fait c'est
même primordial d'être passionné par son
travail et c'est c'est c'est plus
important qu'avant. Donc on va pas
prendre on va pas prendre un métier où
tu tout où tu n'es pas bien. Euh en tout
cas moi c'est ce que je pense c'est
quand je vois moi j'ai beaucoup de
jeunes qui viennent me voir je refuse
jamais un jeune qui veut faire de la
photo, qui vient qui veut me parler même
et je leur dis mais si tu as envie de le
faire-le quoi. Mais il faut que tu as
envie de le faire et surtout c'est
tellement important d'être de faire un
métier que tu aimes, de de te sentir
heureux dans ce que tu fais utile de te
sentir utile.
Alors j'ai pas toujours été comme ça
hein. C'est avec en vieillissant on
essaie d'aller plus peut-être à
l'essentiel. départ, vous étiez comment
?
J'étais très con. Très très con. J'ai
été j'étais vraiment un gosse en guerre
contre la J'étais vraiment un gosse en
guerre contre ma famille, contre j'avais
j'étais viré toutes les écoles. J'étais
vraiment quelqu'un de difficile. Je suis
parti de chez moi très tôt. J'aurais pu
très mal tourner. Puis bon, j'ai eu la
chance. J'ai fait un j'ai fait du
cinéma, j'étais acteur quand j'avais 18
ans. Et c'est drôle parce que euh le
encore aujourd'hui euh
je dis souvent aux jeunes, faut pas
avoir peur de sa chance. La chance, elle
passe pour tout le monde. Faut pas en
avoir peur. Faut pas avoir peur de cette
chance qui passe. Moi j'ai passé ma vie
à attraper la chance quand elle passait.
Et je je me souviens, je voulais je
c'est l'époque où j'étais fasciné par le
cinéma. Je voulais faire du cinéma.
J'étais au cot de Boulogne Bill en cours
et euh j'ai commencé à balayer. Après,
j'ai commencé à faire les ventous,
c'estàd pour empêcher que les voitures
se se garent il y avait des tournages.
Je suis devenu 3è assistante, amène les
cafés puis après je deuxème assistant
puis un jour j'ai fait un un un un test
pour un film d'acteur avec des inconnus.
Je me suis retrouvé à Saint-Tropé en
tournant un film avec Michel Morgan. Euh
et j'étais fou de cinéma quand je me
souviens quand j'avais parti de chez
moi, on ne savait pas où dormir, on
dormait dans les cinémas. On rentrait
par les portes de sortie et on dormait
dans les cinémas. C'est c'est
inimaginable maintenant. Et j'ai vu
comme ça que j'ai vu Citizen Ken une
vingtaine de fois. Donc j'étais très
marqué par ce cinéma. Je voulais faire
du cinéma. J'avais la grosse tête.
J'étais un très mauvais acteur. Donc
j'ai pas j'ai fait qu'un film. Voilà,
j'en ai fait un deuxième au 16 117 par
la suite et voilà et je suis tombé
amoureux de la mère de mon meilleur ami
qui avait 25 ans plus que moi et je suis
parti alors j'avais une famille très
aimante, une famille ouais des gens bien
mais je me suis étais pas du tout à
l'aise avec le carcan religion tu vois
j'étais fou quoi. Je pense qu'il y a un
âge on est on est on est voilà on a
envie de tout casser. Je faisais partie
de c de ces gens-là.
la société qu'on nous proposait ne me
plaisait pas. Et donc j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer cette femme qui m'a
beaucoup aimé et qui m'a fait confiance.
J'ai créé avec elle une réserve
zoologique dans l'allié. Elle avait pas
beaucoup d'argent, elle avait un vieux
château,
une grande propriété et je voilà et
pendant 10 ans, on a monté une réserve
zoologique ensemble. C'est là vraiment
où j'ai découvert ma passion pour le
monde animal et la nature. Donc c'est
cette femme qui m'a voilà qui m'a qui
m'a fait confiance. Voilà.
Vous mangez de la viande ? [rires]
[souffle coupé]
Je mange de moins en moins de viande. Je
suis pratiquement végétarien
et et je je c'est vraiment un combat
c'est compliqué la la
D'abord ce qui est intéressant c'est que
quand tu es écolo, tu sais très bien que
manger la viande c'est pas bon pour
l'environnement. On va on passer autre
chose directement par Allez, on y va. Et
euh et depuis l'an 2000, on en parlait
tous et je me souviens d'avoir été en
2012 à Rio et d'avoir vu un film qui
s'appelle Alma qui est un film qui est
gratuit sur YouTube. C'est par un
réalisateur formidable, un français qui
a fait aussi un film Green sur les
arents Outant. Et ce film, je regarde le
film et en sortant du cinéma, je je dis
je deviens végétarien et d'un seul coup
ça te prend et tu tu as plus envie quoi.
C'est quelque chose de qui qui est
naturel et tu es content d'être
végétarien. Et c'est drôle parce que 2
ans après, je rencontre un de mes
assistants qui était avec moi à ce
moment-là qui était devenu végétarien le
même jour que moi et on l' on se l'était
pas dit. Comme quoi de temps en temps il
y a des films, il y a des moments dans
ta vie qui sont bien faites et qui te
saisissent. étudiant végétarien ou alors
je suis je fais que de temps en temps
des euh voilà, je quelquefois je suis
pas toujours végétarien mais voilà, je
mange très très peu de viande,
pratiquement jamais. Et mais plus que le
problème écologique, c'est la souffrance
animale. Je dois reconnaître que quand
je vois les films de L2, L214, c'est
quelque chose.
Sébastien, bonjour.
Comment
on passe un bonjour à Sébastien.
Ouais. que je trouve que il faut un
travail formidable et que je ne supporte
plus la souffrance animale. Je dois
reconnaître que derrière la viande, je
vois ce qui se passe et ça me
et et c'est très étonnant d'ailleurs
comme
comme on est peu là-dedans en fin de
compte, on est bon, ça commence de plus
en plus. C'est le 214 fait un travail
incroyable. C'est les images, c'est les
les derniers films qu'ils ont montré là
sur une porcherie. C'est les images, tu
même pas envie de les regarder quoi. Ces
cochons en train de pourrir dans le
purin. Tu dis même comment est-ce qu'on
peut en arriver là quoi ? Voilà. Alors,
je te coupe, on va rebondir sur L214
tout de suite. On a accusé de On a
accusé L214 d'être sponsorisé par des
lobby qui faisaient de la fausse viande
complotiste.
Comment
le complotiste.
Le complotiste. Donc, ils ont été
accusés de d'être financé par de par des
des lobby qui faisaient de la fausse
viande.
Vous, on vous accuse souvent d'être
sponsorisé par X ou Y milliardaires, X
ou Y producteur d'énergie, X ou Y
personne. Comment vous
vous percevez ça ? Comment vous vous
réagissez face à ça ?
Bon, j'ai toujours été beaucoup attaqué
quand j'ai fait la terre vue du ciel. Je
me souviens c'était un livre c'était
trop populaire. On m'avait m'avait dit
que c'était des des photos des cartes
postales qui n'avaient aucun sens. J'ai
toujours été attaqué. Toute façon, quand
tu es écolo, tu es toujours attaqué
quelque part parce que tu déranges.
Voilà.
et L214, c'est intéressant de voir comme
le point valeur actuelle a repris ces
ces ces conneries de financement comme
si les les boîtes de viande
industrielle, la viande chimique pouvait
remplacer un jour la viande. C'est
inimaginable. Alors moi je trouve que
j'ai une fondation et que quand on a une
fondation ben il faut la faire vivre et
donc on travaille avec des messes qui
sont pas toujours
non qui sont toujours je pense sincères.
Voilà. Je pense qu'on peut être un
banquier et être sincère. Je pense qu'on
peut voilà, je ne il y a pas d'un côté
les très gentils écolos puis d'un côté
les très méchants capitalistes. Voilà,
on essaie de travailler ensemble.
Quand même des écolos sacrés cons, hein.
Non,
je suis bien d'accord avec toi. Voilà.
Non, mais il y en a autant des deux
côtés quoi. Je veux dire et
même si je me sens plus proche de ces
cons là que les autres, euh voilà. Non
mais je je suis plus c'est drôle parce
que un moment c'était très fort ces
attaques
de mes mess aujourd'hui quoi. Je pense
que c'est beaucoup moins. Je vis avec
voilà mais surtout ce qui m'intéresse
c'est les gens avec qui je travaille je
sente de la sincérité de l'honnêteté.
Voilà tout simplement.
Récemment il y a il y a une agricultrice
qui était pas très contente.
Ouais ouais ouais. On a lu on a lu sa
prose. Vous vous l'avez lu,
c'est très bien écrit d'ailleurs et je
la connais pas. Alors, j'ai essayé de la
rentrer en contact avec elle.
Quel c'était leur proche ?
Les reproches, c'est sur le
l'agriculture intensive américaine que
je reprochais en me disant "nous en
France, on fait pas la même chose."
Voilà. Euh surtout qu'elle avait elle a
fait un papier sur un sur le teaser du
film et je lui ai demandé "Est-ce
qu'elle avait vu le film Moi je connais,
j'aimerais qu'elle me répond qu'elle me
réponde. Non mais c'était
assez étonnamment. Je ça ne j'accepte
ça. Je comprends le je comprends que
quand tu es paysan aujourd'hui que tu
gagnes pas bien ta vie. Il faut faut
savoir que de tiers de paysans gagnent
pas le SMIG. Il travaillent travaillent
pas 35 he par semaine. Voilà c'est
d'agriculture intensive dans lequel ils
sont complètement prisonniers les
rendent pas forcément heureux et je
comprends leur colère. Donc quand le le
le français le le l'Arthus Bertrand, le
l'écolo parisien se permet de critiquer
leur travail, je comprends qu'il y a une
certaine colère maintenant.
400 € de l'heure.
Voilà. Exactement. Exactement. Ça c'est
je ça je l'ai entendu. Il réentendu.
Mais il faut il faut savoir aussi quand
je faisais de l'hélico dans
[raclement de gorge] bon, on va pas
revenir là-dessus mais
non mais on a le temps de quand j'ai
fait la terre du ciel, c'est sûr que je
ferai plus je ferai plus la même chose
aujourd'hui bien évidemment.
Aujourd'hui, il y a les drones et quand
j'ai fait et ce qui est assez étonnant
et et c'est que quand j'ai commencé ce
travail de la terre vue du ciel en 92,
je me souviens, je vois le je vois le le
dans le journal la conférence de Rio en
92 et je me dis j'ai envie de faire un
grand travail sur la terre et très
inspiré par mon copain Salgado qui est
un photographe voilà brésilien
formidable qui a fait un travail sur la
main de l'homme et je me dis je vais
essayer de faire un travail sur le
sur la beauté du monde.
Et donc je pars avec mon hélico. C'est
un travail qui a changé ma vie quoi. Mon
hélico. J'essayais péniblement de
trouver les moyens parce que j'avais pas
d'argent, j'ai hypothéquis ma maison.
Mais je savais que c'était aussi un un
travail qui me
que je faisais un travail qui qui allait
devenir une œuvre. J'avais envie de
faire un travail long
salutaire.
Ça me Et les moments où tu sais que tu
commences dans un travail et que tu sais
que ce travail te dépasse un petit peu,
tu dois aller au bout. J'avais une
équipe géniale avec moi et pendant 8 ans
on a survolé le monde en essayant de
comprendre un petit peu et c'est un
travail qui a changé ma vie parce que je
suis parti pour faire la beauté du monde
et je suis au bout d'un an 2000 j'étais
devenu un activiste. J'ai rencontré
j'avais j'étais passionné d'un des d'un
livre qui s'appelle le World Watch
Institute où chaque année il y avait un
livre à cette époque il sortait aucun
livre sur l'écologie. C'est incroyable
alors qu'aujourd'hui il en sort cinq par
semaine.
Et et donc je je me passionne pour la
révolution verte, pour le pétrole, pour
la pauvreté, pour le les les les
engrais, tout ça me passionne. Et donc
je survole le monde en essayant de
raconter une histoire du monde et je
rencontre des scientifiques. Je
rencontre tous les scientifiques sont
inquiets déjà dans cette à ce moment-là.
Et à ce moment-là, on ne parlait pas du
tout de changement climatique. Le
changement climatique est arrivé avec le
film d'Algor. Voilà. Et et donc je
la vérité qui dérange
la vérité qui dérange en 2003 2004 2005
à ce moment-là on a commencé vraiment à
en parler et moi je fais la terre vue du
ciel je fais mon premier livre sans dire
un mot changement climatique et si je me
souviens très bien quand j'ai fait
l'exposition rue de médicis d'un jeune
touriste allemand qui vient me voir qui
me dit mais est-ce que vous avez pensé
aux énergies fossiles de votre
hélicoptère je dis quoi et donc il me
raconte l'histoire et je et en effet
voilà je découvre ça on en parlait pas
alors peut-être que pourtant Kyoto
existait mais voilà dans les dans les
les gens que je rencontre parlait pas de
changement climatique, je dois que
reconnaître et c'est vraiment quand
Algor est arrivé que ça a commencé, on a
commencé à beaucoup en parler. C'est
là-dessus, j'ai commencé avec le le
qu'on a fait l'émission V du ciel sfant
de on a commencé à compenser le Carbone.
Voilà quoi, on a vraiment pris ça à bras
le corps et on a faisait attention.
Voilà. Donc
on a vu quand on a vu Legacy, il y a il
y a une phrase vraiment qui m'a
touché au cœur.
Merci.
C'est la souffrance de ceux qui savent.
Oui, exactement. Et je pense que Greta
elle
a en elle
ce cette souffrance de ceux qui savent.
Quand on sait, on n'est plus le même.
D'ailleurs, il y a un film que sort un
de mes copains qui s'appelle Emmanuel
Capelin qui s'appelle Quand on sait. Et
je [grognement][raclement de gorge]
crois qu'on sait qu'on sait vraiment
qu'on y croit, on n'est plus le même. Et
c'est pas facile de savoir. C'est
beaucoup plus facile de pas savoir.
C'est pour ça qu'on continue dans cette
dans cette piste de croissance parce
qu'on on veut pas le savoir. Et et je
pense que Greta elle porte en elle Greta
porte en elle cette souffrance.
L'écoanxiété chez les jeunes,
c'est la j'en connais pas beaucoup qu'il
soi aussi en Mais vous imaginez quand
vous avez 20 ans aujourd'hui et que vous
regardez vous regardez le rapport du GC,
vous imaginez vous avez 20 ans, vous
parle de la 6e extinction.
Vous imaginez aujourd'hui quand on vous
parle de que en 2070
3 milliards de gens ne pourront plus
vivre l'endroit où ils vivent à cause du
réchauffement climatique ? Vous imaginez
de de vivre avec ça ? Alors bien sûr
comme personne n'est inquiet, il sont
ils le sont pas tant que ça mais qui est
une colère, je le comprends tout à fait.
Alors là et je serais sans doute moi
aussi plus en colère. C'est drôle parce
qu'il y a pas très longtemps, j'étais
dans une conférence avec Nicolas H. On
était Nicolas, il parle formidablement
d'écologie, il sait parler quoi. Il a il
avait amené un souffle et après on tend
le micro et euh et on me dit "Qu'est-ce
que tu veux dire ?"
J' arrivais, j'ai du mal et j'ai dit
pardon.
Et là, il y a eu vraiment un moment de
silence et j'avais dit le mot juste. Et
l'autre jour, j'ai montré les gassis à
ma vieille tante qui a 92 ans. Elle a
rien dit
et elle m'a dit "Est-ce qu'ils vont nous
pardonner ? fort.
Alors, on a on avait choisi au départ un
titre qui était quand les jeunes se
vengeront
et et on l'a changé ensemble et et il y
a une question en internet sur mon écran
à droite, je vais je vais je vais te la
lire. C'est le titre c'est 50 ans
d'utopie mais c'est 50 ans du passé ou
c'est 50 ans à venir ?
Ben c'est une bonne question. C'est bien
sûr 50 ans à venir. Je pense qu'il y a
un nouveau monde à inventer et que
est-ce qu'on va avoir la volonté ?
Est-ce qu'on va avoir le courage de le
faire ? C'est Algor qui dit est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce qu'il savaient est-ce
qu'ils ont été assez courageux pour tout
changer ou est-ce qu'ils savaient qu'ils
ont laissé faire les choses ? Voilà.
Qu'est-ce que les jeunes nous diront ?
C'est tout est là quoi. Tout est là.
On écoute un petit peu Sensimilia et
dans dans une de ses chansons, il dit
"Heureux les simples d'esprit,
aujourd'hui j'ai compris comment Yan
Artus Bertrand il fait pour être heureux
quand il voit
des catastrophes partout, quand il
survole
des des élevages avec des Comment on
fait pour être heureux C'est
euh
d'ailleurs
comment je fais pour être heureux ?
D'abord c'est
un devoir d'essayer d'être heureux sur
terre hein. C'est on on doit tous
essayer. Ça c'est pas facile parce qu'on
on est rattrapé par la ville les
emmerdes au quotidien. Euh et et c'est
vrai quand tu as des petits enfants euh
quand tu comme moi, tu es passionné
d'environnement, d'écologie, c'est lourd
tout ça en fin de compte. Ça travaille
la nuit. cette moi je et et d'avoir fait
ce film Legacy m'a beaucoup euh euh je
savais pas comment m'en sortir de la fin
du film, tu vois. Et à la fin du film,
j'essayé d'être honnête, de dire
vraiment ce que je ressentais. Euh
est-ce que je suis heureux ?
Ouais, je je suis pas heureux d'en
parler. En tout cas, je suis pas heureux
de dire ça. Non, je suis pas heureux de
le dire. Mais maintenant euh c'est les
c'est drôle parce que le bonheur c'est
des moments euh privilégiés dans ta vie.
Et et quand j'étais au Kenya par
exemple, j'ai passé 3 ans avec ma femme
là-bas. J'étais amoureux. J'avais de
j'avais les les ces deux petits garçons
qui emmené avec moi dont tu as habite
tout à l'heure Baptiste, mon fils.
J'avais et et là je pense que j'étais
vraiment heureux à ce moment-là parce
que je vivais la vie que j'avais rêvé
d'avoir, de vivre au milieu des animaux,
de que ma famille soit avec toutes ces
familles d'animaux. On connaissait les
animaux, une espèce d'harmonie
incroyable, ce qui est unique au Kenya.
Et ça euh c'est une quelque chose que
quel je cours après, c'est de retrouver
cette harmonie avec les animaux sauvages
qui n'ont pas peur de toi. Quand par
exemple, tu es tu sors de ta construit,
tu construis ta maison en bois et tu as
les éléphants qui passent devant ta
maison qui n'ont pas peur. Tu as des des
hippopotames en bas qui n'ont pas peur
alors que ici chez moi Rambouillet, dès
que je sors, je vois des biches au loin,
elles sont terrorisées par moi. Le
renard part en courant quoi. cette
harmonie naturelle avec l'homme a
complètement disparu et et j'étais
heureux là-bas. J'étais heureux parce
que d'abord je faisais ce que je je
rêvait de faire. Qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
plus extraordinaire que de Il faut dire
aussi que j'étais
j'étais un cancre hein et que en France
à cette époque-là, [grognement] j'avais
décidé de passer une thèse, un doctorat
sur le comportement des lions et j'avais
appris qu'on pouvait passer un doctorat
sans avoir aucun au zéro diplôme. Alors,
tu ne peux pas tu peux pas enseigner
mais enfin, j'avais un directeur de thè
s'appelle Pierre Fer qui était un ami
qui avait accepté que moi je le fasse en
photo que ma femme écrivait et je
faisais un espèce de doctorat quoi. un
grand on l'a pas soutenu donc on n pas
été au bout mais on a travaillé pendant
3 ans sur une une étude entre les lions
du Massaimara et les lions du Seringetti
et à ce moment-là j'ai été heureux
véritablement
et je l'ai pas j'ai pas profité de ce
moment. Il y a des moments où tu es
heureux euh et tu le sais pas. C'est
dire tu es bien, tu fais ce que tu as
toujours rêvé de faire, tu as tu as tout
le kit de de l'aventurier, tu vois là,
tu vis au milieu des animaux. Il y a tu
avais et en fin de compte des moments
malheureux, tu t'en souviens toujours,
mais les moments de réel bonheur, je
pense qu'on en profite pas assez. On
n'est pas là et c'est vraiment une
quelque chose que je que je regrette. Et
maintenant d'ailleurs, c'est drôle parce
qu'il y a des moments où j'écoutais
l'autre jour mon fils, mon dernier fils
qui voulait du piano
et et je lisais le journal, il composait
et il chantait. Je me dis mais c'est
peut-être ça le bonheur quoi à ce
moment-là quoi. Tu es là écouter ton
fils qui fait du piano et et c'est des
moments faut profiter des moments de
bonheur. Là est-ce que je suis heureux ?
J'essaye. En tout cas voilà,
je vais prendre une question internet
tout de suite. Vas-y,
vas-y.
Qui est un petit peu piquante puis après
on va revenir sur notre conversation.
Yan Artus Bertrand, l'étard du
consensuel politiquement correct. Que
pensent-il des énergies en dehors du
boboisme écologiste ?
Du quoi ? Du
boboïsme écologiste.
Sa version de l'énergie nucléaire par
exemple qui est la vraie seule
alternative d'énergie de masse sans
dégagement de CO2 face au pétrole alors
que 0.1 % des énergies vertes polluent.
par exemple les panneaux solaires, les
batteries électriques.
Oui, ça c'est un truc, tu vois, que je
vais essayer de je voudrais développer
dans une émission de télévision parce
que aujourd'hui on est un peu perdu dans
la voiture électrique, les éoliennes,
l'hydrogène,
green washing.
Voilà. Non, c'est pas ça. C'est que on
est on sait pas très bien et qu'il y a
toujours des pour et des contes. Tu as
une voiture électrique ou les batteries
ça pollue. Là, construire une voiture
électrique coûte plus cher que mais plus
de CO2 qu'une voiture normale. Voà,
j'aimerais savoir la vérité. Et donc en
permanence, tu as le alors sur le
nucléaire par exemple, moi j'étais très
très antinucléaire très longtemps et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui l'énergie nucléaire
est une voilà est c'est une des
solutions pour avoir une énergie elle
est pas propre. Elle est pas propre mais
elle est beaucoup moins
que que des énergies fossiles.
Maintenant j'ai été à Chernobyl trois
fois je sais ce que c'est qu'un dans le
danger nucléaire.
Il y a des il y a des déchets mais je
pense que les déchets sont beaucoup
moins dangereux pour moi aujourd'hui que
les pesticides qu'on met par tonne dans
les champs tous les jours. Voilà donc
c'est pas une réponse très très juste
certainement mais certainement que le
nucléaire et d'ailleurs je je il y a sur
Netflix un un sujet sur Bill Gates dans
la tête de Bill Gates et la le dernier
épisode c'est sur justement les petites
centrales nucléaires. Je sais pas qu où
est la vérité qui qu'il est en train de
développer en disant que voilà c'est la
ça serait la solution de lutter contre
gement climatique.
Les anglais sont en train de plancher
d'ailleurs sur les microréacteurs.
C'est c'est difficile de et ça voilà
j'aimerais bien faire une émission de
télévision tu vois on on est en train
d'essayer de on va le proposer à France
Télévision comment euh le nucléaire
voilà quel est parce que paraît-il c'est
très difficile de démonteler une
centrale. C'est ça coûte très très cher.
Donc on les laisse on abandonne ça sur
place. Soit quel est le on sait pas très
bien enfin quand il y a toujours un peu
de secret autour du nucléaire et ça ser
j'aimerais bien que ça soit décodé un
petit peu ça. Voilà.
Ils savent pas les démonteler par contre
savent faire des sarcophages.
Exact. [rires] Non mais tu vois alors
les éoliennes il y a des il y a des il y
a du béton tout. Personne ne veut
personne ne veut avoir des éoliennes
chez lui. Les oiseaux maintenant, moi je
moi je trouve des éoliennes soit très
beau des éoliennes bien sûr pas dans mon
jardin si tu veux mais pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs à la limite si c'est utile.
Voilà même chose pour les panneaux
solaires. Il y a toujours des tu sais on
on narrive pas à avoir un vrai
consensus. J'aimerais bien qu'on
décrypte ça, qu'on sache la vérité.
Voilà. J'aimerais bien en tout cas
travailler là-dessus.
On va parler on va sauter encore du du
cocalan.
Les modes d'action des écologistes,
c'est bien les modes d'action des
écologistes. Par exemple, quand on va
s'enchaîner à une station de charbon,
quand on
Ouais, mais je je bien sûr, c'est bien.
Je pense que chacun le fait à sa façon,
d'une façon différente. Voilà. Bien moi
je suis euh jamais je ne critiquerai les
associations écologistes que ça soit les
gens de Greenpeace ou gens de Nicolas
Hul tout ça c'est c'est bien que ça
existe bien évidemment on le fait d'une
façon différente.
Je vais [raclement de gorge] me faire
l'avocat du diable.
Vas-y.
Quand on voit certains militants aller
caillasser des bouchées.
Ouais c'est c'est pas normal. C'est
ridicule. C'est ridicule. Non. Ben bon
mais il y a toujours des excès.
Voilà. Non, je pense que c'est pas juste
tout simplement. C'est ridicule.
C'est quoi la meilleure action pour
protéger la terre ? C'est de mieux
consommer, de mieux voter.
Non, mais d'abord,
c'est déjà de prendre conscience.
C'est c'est c'est protéger la terre, ça
veut rien dire.
Protéger le biotope c'est d'essayer de
conserver la vie telle qu'elle est sur
la terre. Voilà. d'essayer. On faut pas
pas oublier quand même que quand tu
entends Jokovici qui te dit ou d'autres
scientifiques hein qui disent que voilà
le climat qu'on a eu pendant 20000 ans
[grognement]
il est parti il reviendra jamais. C'est
c'est c'est terrible d'entendre ça de
savoir ce climat sur lequel on s'est
installé qui qui est sur lequel notre
civilisation s'est bâtie. Comment est-ce
qu'on peut aujourd'hui
accepter ? Et ce qui est terrible c'est
que on continue comme avant.
C'est-à-dire qu'on sait ce qu'on doit
faire mais on fait le contraire.
Comme le fumeur
quand j'ai quand comment
comme le fumeur.
Oui, un petit peu. Quand j'ai fait le
film home, on consommait 90 millions de
barils de pétrole par jour. Aujourd'hui,
on en consomme 100 millions.
Donc on on fait c'est un peu incohérent.
Et toutes les énergies renouvelables
qu'on a, il y en a énormément. se sont
additionné aux énergies fossiles, ell se
sont pas soustraites. Donc il y a un
problème. Voilà, on est dans un on est
on est dans l'incohérence totale.
Question internet
et et je vais finir sur le l'accord de
Paris. Ce que je dis dans le film qui
est assez quand même flagrant d'abord,
c'est que dans l'accord de Paris, il y a
pas le mot énergie fossile, il y a pas
le mot pétrole, il y a pas le mot gaz,
il y a pas le mot charbon. Sinon, les
pays producteurs ne signaient pas. Tu
dis c'est pas possible. Et euh et on
doit euh pour l'accord de Paris en 2050,
chaque français devrait émettre 2 tonnes
euh de voilà de CO2 de carbone par an.
Aujourd'hui, on a environ 12 tonnes. 12
quoi. C'est avec ce qu'on importe et on
voilà et on a rien fait depuis les 5 ans
qu'on vient de signer. Alors tout le
monde dit "Ouais ouais. Alors Trump
c'est un salot, il a pas il a il veut
sortir. Mais nous qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
nous ? Qu'est-ce que j'ai fait moi en
fin de compte ? Ça qui est intéressant,
c'est ce que je fais moi. C'est pas ce
que fait l'autre. Et et c'est c'est ça
que j'avais envie de dire aujourd'hui,
c'est faut arrêter de penser que c'est
toujours l'autre qui va faire pour toi.
Voilà. Et qu'est-ce quelle est ma
responsabilité ? Qu'est-ce que moi je
peux faire ? Je suis loin d'être parfait
mais de reconnaître que j'ai pas bien
fait, c'est important.
Question internet. Le capitalisme est-il
compatible avec la décroissance ? Quelle
alternative lui semble envisageable ?
Mais tellement compliqué comme question.
On vit le capitalisme, on vit tous du
capitalisme ici. Voilà. Qu'est-ce qui
voilà, on le sait tous. Donc c'est le
capitalisme qui fait vivre qui fait
vivre le monde en fin de compte. Changer
un nouveau système, j'en sais rien. Je
c'est c'est des questions compliquées
ça, tu vois. Moi je je
Tu es pas venu pour pousser un cad hein,
ça c'est sûr.
Non mais je j'ai pas la réponse. Faut il
y a des gens bien plus intelligents que
moi qui peuvent lui répondre à tout ça.
Et d'ailleurs personne n'a la réponse
bien sûr le fond. Même les plus grands
économistes qui ont eu le prix Nobel
sont bien trompés là-dessus. Ça c'est
une certitude
pour développer le le la conscience
écologiste. Mise à part regarder vos
films,
euh il y a des
gens à suivre. Quel quels sont vos
philosophes ? Quels sont vos auteurs ?
Quels sont vos
d'abord maîtres à penser ?
Il y a il y a un grand tissu associatif
formidable en France. et des millions de
gens qui s'engagent qui dans le
bénévolat font des choses formidables et
aujourd'hui les l'écologie est forcément
humaniste. Je crois que c'est une
écologie qui s'occupe des autres parce
qu'en fin de compte d'avoir cette
conscience amoureuse de la vie tout tout
simplement ça ça concerne les animaux,
les pompes, ça concerne aussi les gens.
Et sans doute que le le les écolos ont
peut-être oublié ça que d'abord d'aimer
d'être écolo, c'est bien sûr d'aimer les
animaux, d'aimer les armes, mais c'est
aussi d'aimer les gens quoi quelque
part. Et euh il y a tellement de gens
qui font des choses formidables, des
gens qui s'engagent et ben c'est gens-là
qu'il faut suivre. Il y en a on a
toujours autour de soi, tu as des gens
qui font des choses pour les autres.
C'est vachement important. Et c'est
c'est moi je suis en grande admiration
devant tous ces gens qui d'une façon
bénévole sont été interrogés chez toi de
passer devant une caméra qui font des
choses tous les jours au quotidien sans
en parler. Et moi je me moi j'ai ma
vieille tante qui a 102 ans euh qui
besoin de retraite que j'adore qui est
une bonne sœur formidable 102 ans lisant
la croix tous les jours, décryptant la
croix tous les jours, le journal La
Croix très intelligente et et je vais la
quand je vais la voir il y a pas très
longtemps, je vais la voir dans sa
maison de retraite. C'est pas rigolo les
maisons de retraite hein. Il y a des a
ça sent le pipi, il y a des tas de
couches dans les couloirs. Tu entends
les gens les gens hurler quand
Alzheimer. Il y a pas que ça mais quand
même quand tu montes l'escalier, c'est
pas voilà et et je vais la voir et
j'ouvre la porte et elle m'a accueill un
grand sourire. Je lui dis "Mais comment
tu fais dès que je viens pour avoir ce
si grand sourire ?" Et elle me répond
tac au tac tout de suite mais Yan c'est
pas difficile, je pense pas à moi, je
pense aux autres.
[grognement]
Et si tu veux, c'est quelque chose. Moi,
j'ai pas j'ai pas été j'ai j'étais pas
du tout comme ça très longtemps.
Aujourd'hui, euh j'essaie bah de de
regarder beaucoup plus les autres que de
me regarder le nombril. Et euh ça a
changé ma perception même de l'écologie.
Euh j'ai beaucoup plus de bienveillance
euh contre même les gens qui font des
choses que je n'aime pas. J'accepte. Et
c'est comme ça, je pense qu'il faut
aimer les gens avec qui ne qui ne
t'aiment pas. C'est complètement con ce
que je dis, mais quelque part, il faut
savoir aimer les gens qui ne t'aiment
pas. et et savoir aimer les gens qui
sont pas exactement comme toi parce
qu'ils ont pas la connaissance, parce
que ils sont pas fait comme toi en fin
de compte d'avoir fait le film Human, on
l' on l'a bien montré et c'est quelque
chose et c'est pour ça que je finis le
film sur l'amour et sur la
bienveillance. Je pense que c'est ça qui
nous fera changer les qui l'espoir quoi
parce qu'on est tout on est tous avec
cette espèce d'empathie, cet amour
incroyable pour tes parents. Regarde les
les enfants et après on perd ce côté
d'envie des autres. Voilà d'aimer
d'aimer d'aimer et d'être aimé quoi. Ça
va ensemble tout ça.
On va sauter encore du Calan. C'est
difficile de sauter du Calan avec toi.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est c'est chargé quand même.
C'est Mais ouais mais c'est mouvant d'en
parler. Moi maintenant tu vois.
Bon, compliqué là. [rires]
Après ton film,
il y avait des pubs que pour les
bagnoles.
Je te [rires] C'est vrai hein,
le green washing. Est-ce que tu as pas
l'intention est-ce que tu as pas
l'impression
de temps en temps d'être instrumentalisé
euh par une industrie qui utilise Dian
Artus Bertrand comme une marque pour se
dédouiner de de choses comme ça ?
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Oui,
d'accord. Bien sûr, tu as raison.
D'abord euh
la publicité dans le dans le film
Legacy, moi j'avais demandé qu' qu'on
l'enlève, tu vois. J'avais dit est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas ? Mais c'est une
chaîne commerciale. Fallait accepter à
partir moment où j'ai voilà donc je l'ai
accepté.
Je sais pas le gars qui qui dirige une
une usine de bagnole qui a 50000 mecs à
payer tous les jours, qui doit vendre
des bagnoles.
Voilà son son rôle, son devoir d'essayer
de protéger de l'emploi de l'emploi des
gens. Donc ce n'est pas du green
washing. On est
je je suis plus là-dedans, je suis plus
dans ce côté voilà le méchant
capitaliste et le gentil ouvrier, c'est
autre chose. Non, mais bien sûr qu'il y
a de la du cynisme et du scepticisme.
C'est beaucoup de gens d'accord, faut
l'accepter mais il y a pas que ça.
En terme de d'investissement
responsable,
euh est-ce que toi de ton côté quand tu
produis des films, tu te demandes des
banques par exemple qui n'ont pas
d'investissement dans les hydrocarbures
ou qui ne vont pas faire de
déforestation en Amazonie ou qui n'ont
pas d'action dans l'huile de palme ou
qui s'amusent pas à taper avec des
pelleteuses sur les autant ?
Nous on a comme on a eu moi j'ai fait un
projet comme partenaire qui était la
BNP. Voilà. Donc on a longtemps été en
conflit et on se bagarre et d'ailleurs
dans la fondation Col Planet, on est
toujours on dénonce ces choses-là, on
dénonce. Donc c'est pas parce qu'on a
des partenaires qu'on va pas dire mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
véritable conscience de beaucoup de
gens. Je pense que les banques
françaises sont de loin sont pas les
pires. Voilà. bah tu vois que tu tu
lèves les sourcils. Euh mais euh
ce que ce qu'on ce qu'on dit dans le
film est très juste, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le le pétrole c'est le
sang de l'économie. Donc toutes les
banques dépendent du pétrole, c'est
évident parce que c'est le plus gros
business du monde.
Les banques dépendent du pétrole et
peut-être aussi un peu des pauvres.
[rires]
Euh quand on on parle d'écologie,
souvent on nous objecte ou là là les
cmer verts, la dictature verte euh vous
rendez pas compte, vous imposez, vous
voulez nous imposer, on va perdre nos
libertés avec l'écologie.
Tu préfères perdre tes libertés
et arriver à vivre un peu plus ?
Non mais
tu vois les questions que tu me poses,
qu'est-ce qu' veux que je réponde à ça
Je t'ai dit, tu es pas venu pour un CAD,
hein.
Il y a une il y a une époque où on était
beaucoup plus attaqué que
qu'aujourd'hui. Je me l'époque l'époque
d'Allègre par exemple il y a pas si
longtemps
qui déignait le
Oui. Le le climat scepticisme. Encore
aujourd'hui, il y a très peu de gens qui
nient le qui qui quoi que après mon
film, j'ai comme reçu une trentaine de
mails qui me qui montrent que le le
rechainement climatique a toujours
existé. C'est dans le dans l'air du
temps que l'homme n'est pas responsable.
Blab bla. Il y a toujours des gens qui
te répondent ça comme il y a des gens
aussi qui te disent que l'homme que la
terre n'a pas été faite en 4 milliards
d'années mais qu'elle a été faite en 9
jours. C'est des créationnistes. Je
reçois des mails encore là-dessus encore
aujourd'hui. Donc voilà, donc dès que tu
fais un film sur l'environnement, tu
parles d'une tu parles d'une longue
époque, voilà,
il y a une tendance, il y a une presse
actuelle, c'est vrai, il y a des
une presse de droite qui est souvent pas
très maline là-dessus et qui est ce qui
qui attaque Greta par exemple, elle est
elle est manipulée.
Voilà, il y a des lobby derrière, on
sait bien que c'est ridicule tout ça.
Tu parles de Laurent Alexandre là ? Non
non mais non, je parle de personne. Trop
facile.
Quand quand quand on voit une une
je dirais, je vais pas dire une gamine
mais une adolescente
s'en prendre plein la tête. Oui, mais tu
sais
la py à la limite de la psychiatriser
ou
toi toi le le je vais te manqu de
respect mais le vieil ours qui a
bourlingué qui a vu le le
la merde ça te fait quoi de de voir
d'abord j'ai d'abord je n'ai pas vu la
merde
quand tu survoles quand même une
j'ai vu un monde d'une beauté incroyable
d'abord quand on survole le monde le
monde est toujours aussi beau il faut
des gens me disent toujours. Oui, bien
sûr, tu vois des déforestations, mais tu
vois aussi des des énormes forêts. Bien
sûr, tu vois, en fin de compte, c'est
les photos les photos satellites qui te
montrent vraiment ce qui sont en train
de se passer. Quand tuvoles la terre,
c'est toujours une œuvre d'art, hein.
Faut faut il faut le dire, le la la mer
plein de plastique, tu ne la vois pas.
Les plages sont toujours aussi belles.
Voilà, il faut bien sûr, tu vas tu vas
dans des endroits quelquefois avec des
ouragans tremblementaires, mais en gros,
la terre est toujours une une œuvre
d'art incroyable. Chez qui était quoi la
question déjà ? quand Greta se fait
charger.
Oui, Greta. Alors, Greta elle a cette
elle a ce elle a euh
elle a pris conscience,
elle elle a cette maladie qui lui il y a
pas d'un côté euh voilà, elle est
Asperger, donc si tu veux, elle est il y
a pas de milieu, il y a le bon et le
mauvais. Euh je je moi j'en connais
quelques-uns à Spergurer et je le je le
sais ça. Et donc elle il y a le bien, il
y a la banalité du bien et la bé du
bien. Elle a choisi le bien et donc le
mal elle le supporte pas et comme le mal
et ben c'est le suicide collectif de
l'humanité toute toute sa force, toute
son énergie, elle elle le met au service
d'essayer de sauver le monde comme elle
comme elle peut le faire une fille de 16
ans. Et moi ce qui m'a vachement
impressionné, c'est que euh quand on a
sorti ce film Woman euh qui est un mon
dernier film qui est euh qui est euh qui
va d'ailleurs être le Journée de la
femme sur la 5, qui est un film que
j'adore. On a fait 2000 interviews dans
le monde et j'allais le présenter à New
York. Tu sais quand tu fais un film et
ben tu vas euh de jours à Montréal, une
journée à Rio quoi. C'est ridicule.
À New York ou Nations- Unies.
Oui. Non non à New York. Non pas Nations
Unies. Il y avait une première du film
qui avait été organisée comme font les
distributeurs quand tu fais un film. tu
es distributeur dans le monde entier
quand il disent des premières et tu
avales et tu y vas et tu fais des photos
sur un tapis rouge quoi. Des le grand
classique et [rires]
et je je vais à New York présenter le
film et je l'avais pris euh un petit
bouquin sur les discours de de Greta et
en arrivant à New York, je me dis mais
elle a raison quoi. Et et à 73 ans c'est
l'année dernière, je m'aperçois que je
ne dois pas et en avion à New York
présenter un film 2 jours. On peut le
faire en vidéoconférence, c'était avant
le et elle avait entièrement raison.
Comme quoi euh et j'ai dit à ma voisine
Anastasia Mikova qui est ma
courisatrice, c'est la dernière fois je
prends l'avion. Elle me dit mais comment
tu vas faire ? Moi de bord j'ai 74 ans,
j'ai pris l'avion tellement je suis le
premier. Si vraiment il y a un qui doit
arrêter moi le premier. Comme quoi cette
fille
elle m'a elle m'a voilà, elle m'a
transpercé le cœur par son discours, par
son honnêteté et elle avait raison. Et
elle a raison. Alors après, on s'est
foutu de ma gueule parce que bon voilà,
c'est pas grave.
Ouais, c'est pas grave. On s'en fout. Le
président d'Air France de l'époque
Yan Artus Bertrand découvre quand il
prend l'avion, il pollue. Ouais,
peut-être que je l'avais je je je
croyais qu'on pensait que c'était
suffisant compenser le carbone d'une
façon nous on compense le carbone de
façon solidaire et ce qu'on fait avec la
fondation c'est bien puisqu'on donne on
permet à des des gens qui n'ont pas
d'énergie de faire de l'énergie avec des
réservoirs de biogaz avec de la merde
d'animaux et des déchets agricoles.
arrive à compenser le carbone et à des
familles indiennes de l'énergie, ce qui
empêque la déforestation qui permet aux
enfants d'aller à l'école. On on en fait
des milliers et je suis très fier de ce
programme. Voilà.
Ben, je vais te lire un commentaire
qu'il y a sur notre chat. Ah
oui,
qui dit "Le jour où ces boomers
comprendront que le seul discours
audible de leur part, c'est des plates
excuses. Ils auront fait un grand pas."
Mais je je Ils ont raison. Il a raison.
Il a raison mais on ne savait pas.
Voilà, il a raison. que je vous dise
d'autres. Oui, bien sûr. Mais et je je
vous présente mes plats excuses. Et ça
c'est ça sert à quoi ? Ouais. Maintenant
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on change tous,
toi moi ensemble. Celui qui m'a envoyé
ce ce Bien sûr, il a raison entièrement.
Raphaël.
Raphaël. Mais Raphaël quand
tu as raison.
Quand Camille Étienne est devant le
MDEF.
Ouais. Ouais. Il dit il dit "Bon alors
les gars, il va falloir moins
travailler"
et que tout le monde rigole dans la
salle et que la nana censée être
modératrice lui dit "Bon écoute, ici tu
es au MDF."
Ah oui, mais c'est mais elle était très
courageuse, beaucoup d'admiration pour
elle. Voilà. et Camille que je connais
un petit peu et on a besoin on a besoin
d'elle. Voilà.
Mais il y a espèce de cynisme,
scepticisme, tu vois, qui est dans ce
milieu d'affaires.
C'est tellement plus facile de se moquer
d'elle que dire "Elle a raison,
qu'est-ce que je vais changer ?"
Tellement plus facile de dire "Bah,
c'est on va continuer comme avant."
Est-ce que
c'est plus facile de de pas y croire
hein. Quand tu crois pas, tu continues
la vie au quotidien, tu manges de la
viande, prends ta bagnole, tu prends
l'avion, c'est facile puisque tu as pas
conscience. Mais qu' jour où ta
conscience, c'est plus pareil. C'est
c'est difficile de le faire.
Est-ce qu'on va être obligé de passer
par un événement en France difficile
pour que les gens prennent réellement
conscience genre une grosse clinique ?
Pens des questions mais je ne suis pas
un futurologue. Moi je vis au présent.
Je crois que nous tous ici toi comme
moi, notre le métier qu'on fait a le
devoir d'informer et c'est comme ça que
ça changera. C'est tout. tout
simplement, on a c'est une mission qu'on
doit avoir et on doit tous être capable
de faire quelque chose. Et je répète
qu'on soit boulanger, qu'on soit on a
tout, on peut tous changer notre façon
de vivre. À nous d'y réfléchir et c'est
et c'est compliqué. C'est compliqué.
Je reviens sur le Covid qui est
peut-être une réaction de la terre
face à la mondialisation galopante.
Euh, tu es prêt à sacrifier ta dose de
vaccin pour un jeune ? Mais bien sûr.
Attends, moi j'ai fait ma vie à 74 ans,
c'est bon. Ah oui, complètement. Ah ben
moi, complètement. Ah ben ça va, j'ai
j'ai assez j'ai vécu. C'est c'est normal
de mourir à mon âge. Ça va. Ah non mais
complètement alors là ça ça
m'emmerderait. Mais complètement bien
sûr et heureusement. Et je pense qu'on n
pas les seuls et qu'on est beaucoup dans
mon cas.
Vous êtes beaucoup dans votre cas.
Ouais je pense qu'on serait capable.
Bien sûr. Bien évidemment,
quand on paralyse toute l'économie pour
au départ une bande de vieux
H
c'est quoi ? C'est quoi ? C'est protéger
un socle électoral.
Non mais non mais là ça non mais non
mais non je pense que un gouvernement ne
veut pas se permettre de sacrifier.
D'abord je pense pas que sacrifier des
vieux parce que il y a quand même des
jeunes qui sont malades aussi. Je
connais pas très bien tout ça
des jeunes jeunes malades et on voit
bien aujourd'hui comme le virus bouge,
l'inquiétude qu'il y a et on n'est pas
sorti de l'emmerde et des emmerdes c'est
évident donc je je fais aucune je fais
aucune projection là-dessus non je pense
que c'est normal de protéger nos vieux
bien évidemment parce qu'on les aime.
Quelle quelle quelle analyse euh
quelle analyse Yan Artus Bertrand il a
sur
Mais je je ne suis je enfin
attends je vais faire une question
simple.
Je suis beaucoup plus con que tu crois.
Tu crois tu crois toujours que je vais
Bah, on
n pas encore remarqué. Ça tombe bien.
[rires]
Macron, pour toi, c'est quoi ?
C'est une question conne ça. Non,
je pense que c'est un question euh Non,
non, non. Je pense que c'est un
quelqu'un de brillant euh qui essaie de
faire le maximum avec ce qu'il est, sans
une culture très écolo malheureusement.
Et ça lui manque, c'est dommage parce
que il aurait pu sur les pesticides par
exemple, il aurait pu être devenir un
espèce de quelqu'un qui qui a cour sur
la chasse. Il a pas été assez courageux
mais
mais je pense qu'il fait le job. Euh
voilà, je pense qu'il fait le maximum et
qu'ils essayent un maximum de de sauver
des vies, de faire tenir le pays à bout
de bras et j'aimerais pas être à sa
place. Voilà. Donc voilà. Donc c'est
tout ce que je dis. Je n'ai absolument
aucune animosité contre lui. Et alors le
problème qu'on a en France, c'est qu'on
a pas confiance dans les gens qui nous
dirigent. Moi, j'ai assez confiance.
Parce que tu es vieux.
Ouais, peut-être. Peut-être que je suis
vieux. Mais mais Oui, tu as raison. Euh
j'ai Oui, je pense que voilà, il y a il
y a pas de malhonnêteté. Il y a
là-dedans, il y a simplement l'envie de
Je crois que le poste où il est quand
même,
j'espère que l'ego, l'ego est parti
quoi, qu'il a pris conscience de de sa
responsabilité et ce qu'il doit faire.
Euh qu'il essaie de faire le maximum.
Voilà, je suis pas je suis pas dans
voilà, on on va repartir sur l'écologie.
Euh dans Legacy,
au départ personne t'a invité.
Au départ personne t'a invité pour
Legacy. Tu as eu du mal à diffuser ton
film ?
Non mais c'està dire que
je je je veux
ce que ce que moi je aujourd'hui
j'essaie de dire la vérité, de regarder
la vérité en face sans avoir peur et
sans chaque fois se cacher derrière des
espoirs parce qu'en permanence oui mais
la conscience est là. Oui mais il y a
l'hydrogène. Oui mais il y a la tech.
Oui, mais alors on va y aller, il y a
les smart city, on est dans un espèce de
monde où on s'est euh on s'autoperçoade,
on est piqué au génie humain, on est
certain qu'on va s'en sortir. Donc on
continue comme avant. Et donc ce côté un
peu Pablo Serving, tu vois,
collapsologue, parce que Pablo Serving,
il a cette qualité incroyable, c'est
qu'il est tellement charmant, tellement
charmeur qu'il te parle,
il est il est pas charmeur, il est doux.
Oui, voilà, il est doux, il te dit des
choses épouvantables sur la fin du monde
et tu sors de là avec la pêche quoi.
C'est quand même ça. Oui, mais quand
même, tu vois. Alors que moi, bon, j'ai
peut-être je sais j'ai pas ce charme
qu'il a formidable. Et euh moi, je parle
de la fin du monde, quoi. Je veux dire,
c'est à la fin du film, tu vois bien ce
que je dis. Et c'est pas marrant à dire
ça, tu veux ? Et et qui a envie
d'entendre ça ? Quelle chaîne a envie de
Et il y a qu'une chaîne qui l'a accepté.
J'ai fait, je me suis France Télévision
TF1
euh c'est la 6 qui m'a dit "Ouais,
génial, vas-y, on y va." Et ils m'ont
vraiment fait une vraie, alors c'est une
chaîne commerciale qui m'ont fait
confiance et ce qui était très étonnant
que j'ai trouvé chez M6, c'est qu'il y
avait cette envie euh de faire un film
important, tu vois, qui sentait que et
ils m'ont laissé une complète liberté.
Je dois [grognement] reconnaître que je
suis pas très facile et que personne
voilà, c'est difficile de me faire
changer d'avis, mais euh
voilà, ils m'ont fait changer d'avis sur
une chose euh et je le dis à moment qu'
y avait c ces ces ces élevages de veau
énormes, j'avais j'avais envie de dire
c'est une éternelle choa et en fin de
compte, il m'a dit "Tu peux pas dire ça
et je me bon je ça va faire un un
problème." Mais et il y a un livre
formidable en Angleterre qui s'appelle
l'Éternel Triblinka sur les abattoirs,
fait d'ailleurs par un un historien juif
et donc je l'ai enlevé mais sur le sur
tout le film, il ils m'ont laissé faire
dire ce que je voulais et voilà, ils
l'ont assumé et c'est pas souvent en
télévision qu'on te laisse assumer comme
ça jusqu'au bout parce que tu as des
auditeurs. Voilà. Donc je mais je je
savais que je de toute façon quand tu
euh on c'est un film qui était très
long, on a dépenser beaucoup plus
d'argent qu'on a on y croyait ce film.
Oh c'est un film qui a coûté 5 600000 €
ce qui est déjà beaucoup pour un film
d'archive. Euh et on avait un messen qui
était oméga. J'avais peur de et ils
m'ont laissé faire complètement le film.
Et euh bien sûr il y a M6 qui a financé
un petit peu et euh mais surtout c'est
un film on s'en sortait pas parce que je
les histoires que je racontais
fonctionnait pas et c'est voilà et quand
Franck Courchamp qui est arrivé qui
était un scientifique formidable a
commencé à écrire l'histoire ensemble
euh voilà tout s'est débloqué puis il y
avait des des tonnes d'archives il
fallait qu'on alors c'est a un film
aussi qu'on a fait à l'économie faut
savoir que home ça coûtait 20 fois plus
cher 20 fois plus cher. Donc on a
utilisé tous les archives qu'on avait.
On a on a envoyé des drones dans le
monde entier. On a on a téléphoné à des
dronesques. On fait les images pour
nous. Les images de de des sables
bitmuneux, les images de de de forêt au
Brésil brûlé, les forts les images de de
d'usine de de de carrière de charbon en
Pologne, les images de d'usine de cochon
en Chine ont été tournées par des
locaux. Ouais, c'est une nouvelle façon
de travailler aussi aujourd'hui.
C'est difficile de demander à des locaux
chinois d'aller euh filmer des des
élevages de cochons ou demander à des
Américains de survoler des des usines à
vaches.
Il y a beaucoup de d'ONG chinoises
écolo. Euh en en en Chine, il y a le
pire et le meilleur. Ils ont ils ont
vécu des choses terribles et et alors
c'est un pays qui n'est pas démocratique
mais quand même avec une vraie liberté
de de paroles sur des sur différentes
choses. On peut pas tout critiquer mais
en tout cas voilà, on a beaucoup
travaillé avec des ONG chinoises et et
américaines et brésiliennes. Voilà, il y
a toujours des il y a beaucoup d'images
aussi qui que les images de des des
usines de veau qui sont absolument
invraisemblables parce que ce que les
gens savent pas et moi c'est quand tu
veux de quand tu veux devenir végétarien
c'est que tu dis quand tu commences à
creuser là-dedans, tu dis il faut
devenir végan parce que par exemple moi
tu dis on mange plus de viande, on va
manger du fromage. Alors le fromage bien
sûr, il est fait par des paysans qui
font le fromage chez eux avec leur
laitière, c'est génial. Mais quand tu
vois sur des des fermes gigantes de
milliers de vaches comme il y a beaucoup
aux États-Unis, il y en a pas en France
encore, mais c'est quandme une tendance
quand même parce que le prix du lait est
tellement bas qu'il faut en avoir
beaucoup pour gagner de l'argent. C'est
une honte ça. Comment est-ce qu'en
France on n'est pas capable de payer le
travail correctement des paysans ? Mais
c'est une honte. Aujourd'hui, le prix du
lait, il est payé je je c'était les
chiffres pendant le Covid c'était les
chiffres c'était 0,30 0,30 € payé litre
alors que ça leur revient 0,40. Tu as
des paysans qui suicident toutes les
semaines. C'est c'est honteux comme on
n'est pas capable. Il faut acheter
d'ailleurs le il y a une association qui
s'appelle c'est qui le patron ? Voilà
qui vend qui vend du lait, le fromage au
bon prix. Et qu'est-ce que c'est que
d'être vache la aujourd'hui ? une
Holstein, une vache, une vache, une race
française, une vache canadienne qui
n'existait pas en France dans les années
50 hein. La vache Holstein est arrivée
en France, c'est une vache qui a été
construite pour faire pour faire du lait
avec un pi gigantesque. Le reste, il y a
pas de muscle, rien d'autre. Donc ces
vaches, elles vont vivre 4 5 ans, 3 4
ans, je sais pas exactement. Elles
doivent faire un veau tous les ans.
C'est un petit veau mâle, il va partir à
l'abattoir. Un petit veau femelle, il va
être élevé pour ces fameux cases cases
qu'on voit dans le film. tu dis mais
c'est pas normal, il y a un truc qui va
pas et cette vache, elle va vit 3 4 ans
5 ans et après elle partira à
l'abattoire parce queelle des problèmes
de pile fait trop de lait, elle doit
elle doit être rentabile. Donc il y a un
système où les les les paysans sont
prisonniers de la rentabilité, c'est pas
normal quoi. Pas qu'une vache pive
jusqu'à une dizaine d'années. Il y en a
sûrement des gens qui le font. Il sûrent
des gens qui m'écoutent, faut dire "Mais
moi mes vaches." Oui, sûrement. Mais en
général la viande que vous mangez chez
les McDo, c'est de la vache laitière les
trois/4 tr 3/4 du temps ou euh
et et tu dis voilà euh tu es végétarien
tu devrais être végan quoi quelque part
et tu te dis merde quoi. C'est et tu
n'es pas végan. Voilà. Et
comment quand quand on fait un film
qu'on le tien, comment on décide de le
de la conclusion et comment on décide de
finir face cam ? C'était c'était
Oui. Alors là, c'est c'est bah c'est un
long chemin un long chemin d'essayer des
fins de de parce que quand tu fais des
films écolos, la fin tour des
catastrophes évidemment tu parles
d'avenir donc il fallait qu'on revienne
à l'humain et ce film Human que j'ai
fait que je conseille à beaucoup de gens
de regarder qui est gratuit sur YouTube
qui fait 3h un/4 qui est un film très
long. Euh je peux raconter un peu
l'histoire ? On a le temps. Tu
as le temps. Vas-y.
On a le temps. Alors
tu un petit coup à boire. H ouais, je
veux bien un petit coup d'eau. Non, je
veux bien un petit coup de flotte. Euh
ce que ce que Non, mais c'est bon, c'est
bon, t'embêtes pas, on peut attendre 2
secondes.
Un jour, je suis tombé en panne d'hélico
euh euh sur le Paris, je je faisais le
Paris-Dakar. Imaginez, tu vois, à
l'époque où Paris- Dakar n'était pas ce
qu'il ce qu'il était aujourd'hui. Et en
reconnaissance, on est tombé en panne
avec Thierry Thierry Sabine dans un
petit village.
Feu Thierry Sabine
Feu Sabine. Voilà. Euh et je suis tombé
dans un tout petit village où je suis
resté 3 jours avec des gens qui m'ont
raconté leur vie pendant 3 jours. Euh
tout ce qu'ils m'ont dit, je le savais
déjà. Je savais que par exemple dans un
quand on vit en Afrique et tu as pas de
bras mais tu fais beaucoup d'enfants
pour avoir de l'énergie. L'énergie que
tu as, c'est d'abord tes enfants. Je
savais que euh la météo, tu la regardes
parce que si tu es si tu ne peux pas
cultiver, c'est ce qu'on appelle les
agricultures de subsistance. Ils sont
près d'un milliard dans le monde. Euh
bah que c'est une mauvaise météo, tu
peux pas faire pousser tes récoltes et
donc tu vas mourir de faim. Tu vas
crever de faim. Tu savais que quand tu
es malade, quand tu es malade et que la
malie te fait peur parce que quand tu es
malade, tu peux pas travailler, pas
travailler, tes enfants auront faim.
Tout ça, je le savais. Mais quand
quelqu'un te le dit en te regardant dans
dans les yeux droit droit et ça
transperce le cœur et tu t' tu seul coup
tu deviens moins con. tout ce que tu
savais, c'est c'est pas là, c'est là
tout ça. Et donc, j'ai décidé de faire
ce travail qui s'appelait 6 milliards
d'autres dont Baptiste que tu as vu tout
à l'heure mon fils avait commencé à
travailler à travailler. Il sont j'ai
pris je me suis dit dans mon travail il
manque la parole de l'homme. Euh parler
d'écologie c'est bien mais faut aussi
parler de des gens quoi. C'est la seule
façon de parler d'écologie d'écologie
humaniste. Et donc on avait envoyé une
des jeunes petites caméra qui sont
partis qui ont fait 6000 interview en
demandant un questionnaire qu'ils
avaient fait ensemble. Ils avaient
vraiment tu vois c'est tous des jeunes
qui j'avais dirigé plus ou moins le
truc. J'avais gagné pas mal d'argent
avec le succès de la terre vue du ciel
qui
c'est quoi pas mal ?
Comment
c'est combien ? Oh ben je je pas te
parler de moi j'ai gagné quand tu vends
4 millions de livres, tu gagnes de
l'argent. Tu vois, tu calcules 4
millions de livres, 5 %
[raclement de gorge] de droits d'auteur,
50 % qui vont aux impôts, 50 % que tu
donnes à ta fondation, il te reste quand
même beaucoup d'argent. Et donc ça me
permet de financer, d'avoir financé de
financer un un ce projet qui s'appelait
6 milliards d'autres qui était un nom
qui a été inventé par eux, par ces
jeunes-là. Euh voilà, ils sont partis
partis autour du monde et tout ce on a
fait une grande exposition au Grand
Palais qui a été un énorme succès et je
qui était très addictif où tu écoutais
les gens parler de de leur famille de
euh de de la vie quoi. Qu'est-ce que
c'estvec que le bonheur ? Est-ce quel
est le sens de la vie ? Et les gens
parlaient très très bien et il y avait
25 heures de vidéo et les gens il y a
des gens qui venaient 3 jours pour
écouter les 25 heures de vidéos. Et un
jour, j'ai voulu mélanger dans ce film
Human justement la beauté du monde et la
beauté de ces ces paroles de ces gens.
C'est un film que j'adore. Euh je sais
pas pourquoi je disais ça d'aille je
mais en fait je sais pas de pour d'où on
est venu. Mais en tout cas voilà et
tu es tombé en panne dans hélicoptère.
Oui oui. Donc j'ai j'ai donc je pourquoi
comment j'ai fait ce film Human et en
fin de compte quand fini le film Legacy,
la monteuse Yenne avec que je suis très
proche m'a dit Yan il faut que tu il
faut que tu fasses à la caméra et il
faut comme c'est ton film c'est toi qui
parle la seule façon tout ce que tu vas
dire en voix off c'est ce n'est pas
écoutable si tu le dis si si tu le dis
face à la caméra tu vas amener l'émotion
et ça passera beaucoup mieux que tu dis
sur des images de catastrophe et elle
avait raison et en même temps, j'ai
commencé commencé à faire des essais et
j'ai très inspiré par le film de Netflix
sur Ratenb qui est le gars qui fait
l'émission Wild Life qui a fait un film
sur sa vie et qui est à la caméra face à
la caméra tout le temps et un moment je
me suis dit ben il faut y aller quoi,
faut y aller. Et c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que tu crois de parler face à
la caméra et de de parler de tes petits
enfants, de parler de de la vie autour
de toi qui disparaît. Et c'est quelque
chose qui m'a qui était pas facile à
faire.
Mais je on a on s'est bien on s'est
aperçu puis on a mis les images de de de
Human de ces de ces gens qu'on avait
filmé autour du monde qui ont voilà
parler d'humanité quoi, parler de de
l'essentiel.
Je vais te poser deux questions très
personnelles. Tu es pas obligé d'y
répondre.
Ouais,
ça c'est sympa de dire ça. Alors tu vois
tu vois voyez comment il fait le mec là
? Tu as posé une question et donc si tu
réponds pas, tu as l'air d'un tu enfin
bon un mec d'un con [grognement]
prétentieux qui veut pas répondre aux
questions, pas directement. Non,
je parle à la caméra directement parce
que vas-y.
Est-ce que tu es croyant ?
Là, je peux répondre alors très
bassivement. Je ne suis pas croyant mais
par contre je crois au bien et au mal.
Voilà, je donc c'est un peu la même
chose et et je pense que les valeurs qui
qui sont portées dans toutes les
religions au départ du bien ou des mal
du mal voilà font partie de de du c'est
comme comme ça qu'une civilisation
marche quoi. En étant en allant plutôt
vers le bien et en ce moment nous vivons
dans espèce de banalité du mal. On
accepte le mal autour de nous et voilà
il faut faudrait pas l'accepter.
Est-ce que tu as fait une psychothérapie
? Non, j'ai j'ai j'ai une femme qui est
euh qui est psychothérapeute et qui m'a
toujours dit que je devrais en faire
une, mais euh je non, j'ai pas très
envie.
Pourquoi ?
Je j'ai l'impression de de me de me
connaître. Euh, je sais pas, je je pas
envie. Voilà. Ça fait pas peur. Ça me
fait pas peur. Non, non.
Si si je te dis le mot résilience, ça te
fait penser à quoi ?
Moi, je vais te le dire. À quoi ça me
fait penser ? Ça me fait penser
[soupir]
aux femmes Yezidi
que j'ai interrogé que nous avons
interrogé sur Woman et qui explique ce
qu'elles ont vécu.
Ce qu'elles ont vécu quand elles ont été
vendues violé des enfants violés qu'ils
en elles en parlent
avec résilience.
cette espèce de force incroyable qu' les
femmes pour supporter cette douleur et
de continuer à vivre. Quand tu vas chez
le docteur Mebé au Congo, ces femmes qui
sont violées avec des coups de couteau
et qu'elle te raconte ça et qu'après tu
les vois
dans le film, moi on l'a pas mis dans le
film mais Anastasia en train de danser,
de rigoler entre ell après ce qu'elles
ont vécu. C'est ça la résilience.
Peut-être que c'est pas le bon mot, mais
en tout cas la résilience c'est ça pour
moi. Ce courage incroyable. qu'on les
femmes après ces milliers de générations
de violence, d'accepter de la douleur,
de vivre avec
beaucoup d'admiration.
Question internet, je prends la première
qui vient. Pourquoi certains n'ont pas
de chance ? Alors
pourquoi pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ? On a pourquoi certains n'ont
pas de chance ?
Je pense que alors tu vois par exemple
sur euh quand j'ai fait human,
ce qui m'a beaucoup impressionné c'est
les parents d'enfants handicapés.
C'est lourd hein comme interview
aujourd'hui. Et je pense que ça c'est
pas de chance. En même temps, il y a des
des des l'amour incroyable de
C'est une chance. C'est peut-être
peut-être peut-être peut-être mais oui,
tu as raison. C'est c'est c'est pas ce
que ce que je voulais dire, je regrette.
Mais cet en tu perds une liberté quoi.
Tu perds une liberté.
Et dans le film Woman, cette femme qui
parle de son enfant autiste, elle me dit
il me regarde jamais, il ne m'embrasse
pas, il a jamais un geste tendresse vers
moi et pourtant je l'aime, tu vois. Et
voilà, je pense que d'avoir un enfant
handicapé et dans je me souviens de d'un
d'un père qui parlait de son enfant
autiste euh quand il allait une fête de
Noël, on lui reprochait, on dit "Quand
un enfant comme ça, on sort pas dehors
avec lui, on va pas au restaurant." Et
il disait un truc terrible, terrible,
terrible. Il disait "Un moment,
"J'attends la mort.
[soupir][grognement]
C'est pas moi qui le dit, c'est lui.
Comment tu veux comment tu vois ta
propre fin de vie ?
Ah, j'ai j'ai j'ai une je l'ai beaucoup
raconté cette histoire, mais je désole
de la raconter. Encore une fois,
j'ai quand on était à Madagascar et
qu'on avait fait on a photographié sur
Human, on a fait des interviews de
Human, il y a une
femme dans ces interviews qui sont
toujours des questions pose toujours les
mêmes. interview qui dure 1 heure 2h et
on a parlé avec une femme qui s'est
agric de subsistance toujours pareil des
gens extrêmement pauvres ça pas lire pas
écrire on est là avec enfin avec nos
caméras on s'installe et on demande à
ces gens de raconter leur vie et en fin
de compte ils ont jamais parlé devant
une caméra ils savent ils comprennent
même pas où ce qu'on va faire des images
mais en même temps on est là on leur
parle on est on passe des moments avec
eux
et une question qu'on pose aux gens quel
est votre plus grand rêve
Et cette femme
plus grand rêve, elle commence à parler
de la la mort de ses enfant parce que
quand tu fais beaucoup d'enfants, tu as
beaucoup d'enfants qui meurent donc elle
parle voudrait que mes enfants vivent.
Elle avait un bébé qui était malade.
Elle veut l'éducation pour ses enfants
parce que partout où tu vas, les mères
leur principal objectif c'est que leurs
enfants réussissent leur vie et soient
meilleur que ça c'est vraiment
incroyable. l'espèce de volonté
incroyable des femmes que que leurs
enfants vivent une meilleure vie qu'elle
et on lui dit mais non mais quelque
chose de plus fort quel est ton plus
grand rêve ? Alors elle elle réfléchit
réfléchit elle parle avec sa copine dans
le dialecte malgache que je sais pas si
elle parlait je sais même pas ce qu'elle
parlait enfin je entends rigoler elle me
regarde droit dans les yeux et elle me
dit un truc à laquelle je pense tous les
jours. J'aimerais mourir avec le sourire
ça veut dire quoi ?
C'est formidable. L'intelligence, ça
veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire qu'on va
tous mourir,
c'est écrit, qu'il faut accepter sa
mort, ce qui est pas facile, mais qu'il
faut
régler ses avoir vu la vie qu'on qu'on a
envie d'avoir quoi. pas d'être fier de
sa vie, ça veut rien dire, mais de
d'être content la vie qu'on a eu,
d'accepter ses erreurs, racepter ce
qu'on a fait pas bien, de de le de de
demander pardon, j'en sais rien, mais en
tout cas de
d'accepter la vie qu'on a eu et dire
merci à la vie. Et ça, c'est vachement
important et j'y pense tous les jours.
Et d'ailleurs la fin d'human, c'est
quelqu'un qui dit "J'aimerais que mes
derniers mots soient merci, merci à la
vie.
Bon, on change un peu de sujet parce que
ça commence à devenir un peu lourd. Euh
mais tu sais de parler de l'amour, de
parler, c'est c'est essentiel. Qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de plus important que ça en
fin de compte ? C'est plus
alors question qui n'est pas une
question internet qui est une question
de mon ami sur la gauche que je balance.
[rires]
Comment en tant qu'homme tu fais un film
sur les femmes ? Quelle place tu as par
rapport à une femme qui pourrait le
faire ? Alors,
comment tu te lais comment tu leur
laisses la place
et le choix que tu coupes pour le
documentaire ?
Alors
tiens, mais tu veux pas la lire ta
question ?
Alors, je vais te répondre à je vais te
répondre à toi parce toi qui a posé la
question. J'ai pas non, je r c'est toi
que je réponds je dit. [grognement]
Alors, c'est très simple, je décide de
faire un film sur les femmes et je
m'aperçois que je peux pas faire un film
les femmes tout seul. Voilà. Donc je
demande à Anastasia Mikova avec qui j'ai
beaucoup travaillé de faire le réaliser
le film avec moi. Elle choisit son
équipe avec moi et je m'aperçois très
vite que je suis pas exclu du film,
c'est pas le mot, mais que c'est un film
fait par des femmes et que je je dirais
pas fermer ma gueule, c'est pas le mot,
mais que je dois laisser la liberté à
ces femmes de faire le film qu'elles ont
envie. C'est pas toujours facile que je
suis quelqu'un d'assez autoritaire. Et
en fin de compte, je crois que le film
est très bon parce qu'il a été fait par
des femmes. Par exemple, tu vois, à un
moment euh elle me dit "Faut parler des
règles." Bon, moi je Oui, pourquoi pas ?
Mais je vous pose un peu la question et
je m'aperçois que toutes les femmes avec
qui on parle te parlent quand les règles
arrivent de l'importance que ça a dans
leur vie. Et moi, j'ai absent pas
compris ça. Les femmes qui saignent tous
les mois, c'est la douleur, c'est
compliqué, c'est voilà. et il fallait
que des femmes parlent de ça. Par
exemple, la naissance de la sexualité.
Quand tu es une jeune adolescente, que
les hommes te regardent d'une façon
différente. Comment est-ce que ça change
toi ? Moi, je je suis incapable de
comprendre ça. Bé et on était il y avait
une équipe de 18 personnes, on a
travaillé quand même pendant 2 ans. Euh
j'avais on était deux mecs, on avait pas
le pouvoir et j'ai à un moment j'ai
senti que j'avais que je devais laisser
les choses que le film allait être bon
parce que c'est des femmes qui le
faisaient. Donc ça pas du tout été
difficile pour moi parce que j'ai bien
compris que le film serait meilleur si
je laissais les les femmes faire le
film. Voilà, j'espère qu'on sera on va
être au César bientôt. J'espère que
voilà qu'on va y aller. Euh et c'est un
film formidable mais
je me dis pas que je me suis sentiu
exclu du film, c'est pas vrai. Mais j'ai
j'ai compris qu'à un moment il fallait
que je laisse laisse le pouvoir euh aux
femmes de l'équipe. Voilà. Bon, je te
dis pas que j'ai pas décidé de beaucoup
de choses. J'ai sûrement été beaucoup
plus euh j'ai sûrement été beaucoup plus
euh autoritaire que je le dis
maintenant, mais j'ai j'ai quand même
voilà, j'étais j'avais compris c'était
c'était c'était c'était normal qu'il
fallait que je laisse le pouvoir. Voilà.
Mais c'est un film, je peux te dire que
d'abord c'est un film où je me suis
senti femme pendant 2 ans. Parce que
quand tu fais 2000 interviews de femmes
qu'elles te racontent leur vie, voilà de
leur enfance, les la la maternité, la la
qu'est-ce que tu as entendu de choses
formidables, quelle intelligence, quel
bon sens. Mais je me suis vraiment senti
un mec con, tu vois, devant
l'intelligence de toutes ces femmes. Je
dois reconnaître. Et certainement, je
dis pas avec fierté que j'ai
certainement pas assez respecté les
femmes de ma vie, tu vois. Et
aujourd'hui, que ça soit de ma mère, que
ce soit mes sœurs ou ma femme, je les
vois différemment, complètement, mais
j'ai vécu pendant 2 ans de l'intimité
des femmes et ça m'a rendu
moins con. Et il y a du chemin à faire,
je veux dire, c'est [rires] je
Tu pars de loin, c'est ça ?
Oui, je pars de très loin.
Moi, je voudrais qu'on parle de la
moralisation de la vie politique.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux m'en dire ?
C'est [grognement] encore un bullshit,
un un un effet de Non, pas du tout, pas
du tout. Mais tu vois quand je voyais
l'histoire là du procès baladure
dernièrement, tu vois sur le Pakistan,
je me suis dit comment
sur Karachi
Karachi comment il faut 18 ans ou 20 ans
pour faire un procès alors qu'un mec qui
volait une mobylette euh il va être jugé
dans les 6 mois. Là, je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose qui va pas. On attend que
tout le monde Je sais pas, je tu vois
voilà
je je pense que l'homme politique dev
enfin bon c'est une espèce de rêve tu
sais. H je je
moi j'attends les grandes âmes les
grands hommes, tu vois, les gandies, les
grandes femmes les grandes femmes
quoi. Ouou les grandes femmes bien sûr.
Bien sûr, on parle des grands hommes
bien sûr. Et on peut parler des grandes
femmes écolo parce que toutes les héros
de l'environnement en parlant de
Carlson, Vanonashiva, c'est tous des
femmes. Toutes les héros de
l'environnement sont des femmes jusqu'à
Greta aujourd'hui. Donc voilà. Donc je
mais si tu veux je je en ayant un manque
de confiance dans nos hommes politiques
euh terrible euh voilà qu'on a pas envie
de suivre et voilà d'oralisation d'homme
politique bien sûr mais je je connais
pas assez bien ce monde là je ne je je
vois ça de très loin voilà je crois
voilà mais cette histoire de karachi m'a
ça m'a quelque chose de pas normal quoi.
Voilà. Et quand tu vois des hommes
politiques qui étaient condamnés, qui
sont réélus, voilà le le maire de
Levalois, tu dis "Mais attends, merde,
c'est pas possible quoi. Comment est-ce
qu'on peut ?" J'ai rien contre ce type
mais voilà que tu sois un homme
d'affaires et ça pas mais quand tu es un
homme politique et que tu que c'est
l'argent des électeurs, ben voilà, tu tu
dois pas voler un centime quoi, tu vois.
Et si tu es préqué à faire ça, tu ne
dois plus jamais faire de politique de
ta vie. Et pourtant, on ils refont de la
politique et ils sont réélus. Donc voilà
euh
ça s'appelle de la subordnation de vote.
Ça s'appelle
Je sais pas.
Est-ce que tu peux m'expliquer
m'expliquer ce qu'est l'affaire du
siècle ? Oui. Euh
je je
Oui, c'est ce ce procès euh qu'on a fait
au l'homme politique sur euh
condamnation qui n' je dois reconnaître
que je me suis assez éloigné de ça parce
que j'ai pas j'ai pas cette certain
cette certainement cette cette haine
cette cette envie de vengeance que j'ai
pour ma génération. Voilà, que peut-être
des jeunes peuvent avoir et qu'ils ont
qu'ils doivent avoir. Peut-être que j'en
fais partie. Et en même temps euh je
suis l'État, je suis les entreprises, je
suis le citoyen. En moi, il y a tout ça.
L'État c'est moi. Si euh on va en parler
si tu veux. Moi, je suis très euh
concerné par le fait que mon pays est le
troisème vendeur d'armes au au monde et
ça je l'accepte pas, tu vois, de penser
qu'aujourd'hui Yen, le Yémen,
voilà, voilà le pays, on vend des armes
à l'Arabie Saoudite qui vont bombarder
le Yémen
ou le Yémen ou un autre pays.
Aujourd'hui, dans les guerres
d'aujourd'hui, il faut savoir que 80 %
de civils sont tués. Sur les 80 %, il y
a 30 % d'enfants. Comment mon pays que
le pays des droits de l'homme, le pays
des ONG,
pays de la générosité, on est encore le
troisème vendeur d'armes au monde. Ça je
ne l'accepte pas. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on
pourquoi ? Parce qu'on a besoin
d'acheter ce [__] de pétrole qui est
le seul de notre économie et si on n pas
ce pétrole, l'économie s'arrête, notre
pays s'arrête. Donc, on a besoin de cet
argent. Donc, on est prêt à faire
n'importe quoi pour avoir ce pétrole.
Mais je ne j'imagine le type qui qui
fabrique des missiles euh voilà dans une
usine d'ailleurs on ne peut pas rentrer.
J'ai une copine qui a fait un film qui
s'appelle Mon pays le 3è V mon pays vend
des armes. Impossible de rentrer dans
une usine d'armement c'est strictement
impossible. Et j'imagine le mec qui
fabrique toute la journée des des
missiles et qui le soir rentre chez lui,
discute avec ses enfants quoi. Je me dis
mais voilà tu vois et
je je j'ai rien à lui dire tu vois c'est
pas moi de le juger.
Est-ce que tu as suivi le mouvement des
gilets jaunes en France ?
Ouais ouais bien sûr.
Est-ce que tu as suivi euh les
mutilations des gilets jaunes ? Est-ce
que tu as suivi les mutilations chez les
gilets jaunes ? fait qu'il se prennent
des balles dans la tête, qui se prent
des balles dans les yeux, qui se
prennent des balles dans les parties
génitales.
Le fait le fait qu'il se fasse
matraquer, gazer, coffré, foutu en tôle,
condamné
et que Balcani passe moins de temps en
confinement que en tôle. En tô com en
confinement.
Ouais. Euh d'abord quand tu quand tu
Alors ce qui m'a beaucoup choqué sur le
sur les gilets jaunes,
c'est espèce de haine qu'il y avait
contre le les policiers contre le et je
Ouais je et je pense que bien sûr et je
pense que
le pauvre CRS qui est en face c'est un
gilet jaune quelque part
c'est un pauvre qui tape sur un pauvre.
Voilà, je pense qu'il y a deux personnes
l'un en face de l'autre et quand je me
souviens d'entendre, tu te souviens, il
y avait eu un suicide et il y a des gens
qui criait "Suicidez-vous,
débarrassez-nous".
Horrible.
Ça m'a assez choqué
et il y a un moment
où la haine te rend con, tu rends tu tu
fais n'importe quoi, tu vois. Tu n'es
plus tu es plus un mec normal, tu es
prêt à tuer, tu es prêt à taper des deux
côtés. Voilà, c'est j'ai pas de j'ai pas
de jugement à faire ça. Je pense que
peut-être que moi qui a fait mes 68, moi
qui aussi qui était aussi dans la
violence, j'aurais peut-être fait la
même chose. Donc
ta cassé du condé.
Ouais, mais j'aurais vous voyez que pas
de loin, c'était un peu le petit
bourgeois en lançant des pavés de loin
avec des bagnoles qui brûlaient. C'était
quand même moins violent qu'aujourd'hui.
Beaucoup moins violent même si on avait
envie de tout casser. Et c'est normal
d'avoir envie de tout casser, je pense
quand tu as 18 ans. Tu as envie de
casser le système, c'est humain. Mais
les gilets jaunes, moi j'ai interrogé
j'ai fait des femmes de gilets jaunes
dans mon dans mon dans [grognement] dans
mon film et quand elle te raconte qu'une
une femme de qui gagne 1200 € par mois,
voilà, qui a deux enfants euh être
soignant 1200 c'est déjà beaucoup.
Voilà 1000 soignantes qui touche que le
mari ne paye pas sa pension. Et bien, on
en a interrogé qui m'ont c'est des
interviews qui m'ont fendu le cœur
véritablement et je comprends cette
colère. Il y a une il y a une
répartition des richesses qui n'est pas
juste et moi je suis un privilégié, je
le dis et le redit donc mais j'en ai
vraiment conscience et c'est pas normal.
C'est pas normal. Voilà.
Ga Girot, ça te fait penser à quoi ? un
ami que j'adore, quelqu'un de bien, un
virtuos au piano. Voilà, c'est un type
qui est formidable et euh ce type qui
est jésuite, qui euh qui est brillant,
qui a été un qui a été un trader, qui
est capable aujourd'hui de d'être un
homme d'église, moi je suis pas croyant
mais je suis en admiration devant ça et
qui donne 100 € par qui garde 100 € par
mois. son salaire est donné à la
communauté. Beaucoup d'admiration,
d'intelligence, on devait c'est drôle
parce qu'on avait un on avait un projet
de faire un livre ensemble tous les deux
[rires]
cit une idée d'un éditeur pu je me suis
dit je vais pas être au niveau du tout
tu vois je vais être je vais pas être au
niveau. Donc je vois quand j'ai décliné
en me disant bah attends quand tu fais
un bouquin avec un mec qui est si malin
si intelligent tu dis non ça va pas
marcher. Donc je l'ai pas fait.
On a fait une interview de lui.
Oui je l'ai vu.
C'est pour ça c'est peut-être pour ça
que je suis là aussi aujourd'hui tu
sais. Pourquoi ?
Parce que je trouvais que tes interviews
sont longues, tu prends le temps
d'écouter les gens et puis en fin de
compte ce que j'avais pas ressenti,
c'était assez d'empathie envers les gens
que tu interview quelque part. Tu tu
aimes bien les gens que tuinterview
parce
faut pas le dire, faut pas le dire.
Non mais c'est important de tu de tu
sais parler aux gens quoi. Tu sais
voilà, tu te
je C'est comme ça que je le ressens.
J'avais un peu peur en arrivant. Bah
écoute, tu as pas été dans la cave donc
ça va parce queavant avant on tournait
dans une cave mais la communauté nous a
un peu aidé pour sortir de notre cave.
Ça y est, je rougis.
Non, le plus jussif avec l'interview de
Galgiro, c'est on a une question qu'on
pose un petit peu d'une façon piquante
qui est-ce que vous avez un ami
imaginaire pour faire référence si vous
êtes croyant ou pas croyant ? Et quand
en face on a un jésuite
qui a fait
une thèse ou un doctorat sur
théologie Oui. Sur le
la théologie et les l'écologie. Voilà.
Oui oui oui bien sûr. C'est difficile à
comprendre.
Ah c'est c'est il faut mâcher.
Tu l'as entendu ? Non mais il est
brillantissime. Il est brillantissime.
Ou
qu'il y a d'autre de brillantissime
encore en France ?
Bah, c'est peut-être la sœur Marie Jo
qui est une bonne sœur qui reçoit des
réfugiés tous les jours que que je
connais bien qui est dans le sous-sol de
son église de la porte de Chapelle parce
que les réfugiés quand ils arrivent en
France, ils connaissent la sœur Marieot
parce que ça ça se passe et quand ils
arrivent, ils vont directement la voir
pour avoir
des des vêtements, pour avoir de
l'argent, pour qu'on l'aide. Et voilà,
ça c'est des gens que qui parlent pas la
télé, qu' personne ne connaît, qui font
un travail incroyable. C'est c'est cela
que j'admire et il y en a beaucoup, je
peux te dire ça.
Cédou
bah Cédricou c'est j'ai j'ai je je il a
il a il a cette côté
naïf, utopiste, courageux. Voilà, on a
c'est c'est des gens qui sauvent nos
âmes, ces gens-là qui sont importants,
hein, les gens de SOS Méditerrané.
et je suis en grande admiration devant
ces gens. J'essaie d'aider comme je
peux.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux dire aux gens qui
sont pas contents par exemple du travail
de Cédricou avec les réfugiés, par
exemple avec le travail de SOS
Méditerranée pour protéger le des vies
en Méditerranée ? Quand quand ils disent
voilà ces gens-là sont des importateurs
de terroristes, des importateurs de
misère, des complices, des passeurs.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut leur dire à ces
gens-là ? [soupir]
[grognement]
D'abord, il faut leur dire que quoi
qu'ils pensent, la grande crise
migratoire n'a pas encore commencé. On
est au début de quelque chose qui va
être beaucoup plus important qu'on
croit. [grognement] On l'a dit tout à
l'heure, mais quand tu vis dans un pays,
ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est qu'il a
énormément changé de choses. Il se
trouve que je j'ai beaucoup de de jeunes
que je connais euh qui vivent dans les
pays africains et tous les gosses, ils
ont WhatsApp aujourd'hui, ils savent,
ils ont internet. Donc le gosse
adolescent qui vit à Disaba, qui vit à
Bamo, il sait très bien comme on vit, il
sait ce qui se passe ici. Et donc ce
paradis qu'il n'a pas chez lui puisque
je répète, il a pas de travail, il a pas
de démocratie, il a pas de sa santé, pas
d'éducation, il a qu'une envie, c'est de
venir chez toi. Et donc tous ces jeunes
ne parlent que d'une chose toute la
journée, comment on va partir ailleurs ?
Comment on va réussir à parler aux
copains com ils sont là-bas ? Et quand
tu vois un mec qui balaye dans la rue
un black, souvent euh il faut imaginer
d'où il vient le type hein. Faut
imaginer ce qu'il fait. Souvent c'est
des maliens dans la famille a payé le
voyage. Il envoie une partie de son
salaire à sa famille qui l'attend
là-bas. Et je le regarde d'une façon moi
avec respect ce type là, tu vois, qui
vient ici nous nous aider à vivre mieux
pour que sa famille vive d'une façon
meilleure chez eux. Et
le fait de j'ai la chance d'avoir
voyagé, d'avoir rencontré beaucoup de
gens, ça a développé peut-être chez moi,
peut-être que c'est une chance, tu vois.
Je fais toujours partie d'une famille.
Ma mère déjà faisait de la de
l'éducation euh de la
Tracato qui faisait de la tu vois de la
comment elle s'apprenait à lire au
réfugiés déjà dans les années des années
70. Donc j'ai été levé un peu là-dedans
et puis moi euh les plus belles années
de ma vie, je les ai passé en Afrique
quoi. C'est des gens que j'aime.
Et cette souffrance
que tu vis dans ce pays-là, tu peux pas
la refuser. Il faut que tu l'acceptes.
Tu peux pas refuser quelqu'un qui vient
qui a risqué sa vie, qui risquit sa vie.
Des milliers de morts chaque année qui
méditer, je suis désolé.
Bon, vas-y, je vais faire le con pendant
Vasy, fais le con. Vas-y. [grognement]
En
c'est drôle qu'en vieillissant, je
je suis de plus en plus sensible. Je
sais pas pourquoi. Pourquoi je me mets à
pleurer là-dessus ? C'est un peu con.
Les migrants climatiques.
Alors, les migrants climatiques,
a quelqu'un qui t'a dit le migrant
climatique. Alors, on parle de de
millions de millions, hein, ça ce que
dit les Nations Unies. Mais aujourd'hui,
c'est beaucoup plus des migrants qui
fuient la guerre. Tous les des Syriens
de Soudan, tu vois, gens qui peuvent
vivre chez eux puis surtout des des
migrants économiques. Je répète
aujourd'hui, il y a la la l'information
passe tellement bien, tu vois, de
comment nous, on se rend pas compte
comment on vit ici. Quand tu vas quand
tu vis à Brazaville, tu vas dans
l'hôpitaux, il y a pas de médicament, il
y a pas de pensement et ça n'existe pas.
C'est tu vois, il y a il y a pas
d'assurance sociale, tu vois. C'est on
on et et tu vis dans un pays, on te dit
ben on t'appelle c'est génial en France.
Dis donc tu viens en France, tu tu es tu
es réfugié, tu tu as 400 parce que en
réfugié touche s'il est accepté, il
touche 400 € par mois. 400 € par mois
c'est c'est gigantesque quand tu vis à
Bamaco. Donc voilà, il y a une espèce de
d'envie et et mais il faut savoir que
depuis le début de l'humanité, c'est la
ronde infernale, c'est normal d'aller
avec ta famille où tu vas vivre mieux.
C'est l'histoire du monde. Voilà. Quand
quand il y aura avec 8 milliards 8
milliards de personnes, c'est plus
compliqué que quand il y en a qu' avait
quelques quelques millions. Mais voilà,
c'est c'est normal que les que les gens
viennent chez nous.
Question d'Internet,
un avis sur la chasse, c'est mieux ou
c'est pire que l'élevage ?
Alors euh moi j'ai été chasseur quand
j'étais quand j'ai 20 ans, quelques
années, pas longtemps.
La plume à poil.
Oh, c'est compliqué. Mais
j'ai [grognement] pas beaucoup parlé de
ça. Mais c'est vrai que j'ai
je quand je suis rêvé dans ces quand
j'avais 20 ans, l'en cit une réserve de
chasse. Et donc, il y a des gens qui
venaient qui payaient pour chasser et
moi mon rôle c'était souvent de d'aller
ramasser les animaux qui étaient morts,
qui avaient été blessés, qui avaient pas
été dans la forêt. Donc, on cherchait
les animaux. Et un jour, j'ai trouvé un
sanglier qui avait pris une balle dans
les qui avait les deux pattes coupées,
qui avait une qui avait eu la mâchoire
arrachée et qui un animal qui aurait dû
peser 100 kg, qui devait en pè 20, tu
vois et qui était pè d'animal comme ça.
Et j'ai plus jamais touché un fusil de
ma vie et je l'ai c'est moi qui l'ai tué
avec un couteau suisse tout petit
couteau suisse. et ça te vois et mais en
même temps voilà on vit dans un moi je
vis dans la forêt de Rambouillet et
j'essaie d'endroit où j'habite
j'aimerais pouvoir interdire la chasse à
l'endroit où je vis quo faire une espèce
de un moratoire ou quelques années on va
d'arrêter les le la chasse
parce que je pense que de voir
une biche ou un ser
à côté de toi dans un dans la forêt
c'est un cadeau formidable
Et ça a beaucoup plus de valeur de voir
un animal mort. Cet animal, il va faire
plaisir à beaucoup de gens. Et
d'ailleurs, j'ai même un projet avec la
on a pas parlé de ma fondation GL
planète parce que j'aimerais qu'on en
parle parce que c'est important.
J'aimerais essayer de mettre c'est une
idée complètement folle de mettre dans
le bois de Boulogne des sers et des
biches. Voilà et j'adorais avoir des
entourer 3 4 hectares de mettre des
animaux et après d'ouvrir les barrières
que les animaux puissent sortir. Ça
existe dans les parcs en Angleterre, ça
existe dans un parc au Danemark où tuas
tuas un bois très proche de la ville.
des cres et des biches que tu approches
très près et ça sera un cadeau
formidable pour les Parisiens d'avoir
une forêt avec des animaux sauvages à
l'intérieur. Alors bien sûr ça serait
compliqué pour les bagnoles, bien sûr
compliqué pour les forestiers mais ça
vaut le coup d'essayer parce qu'on vit
dans un monde où l'animal sauvage
dérange et gêne. Donc moins il y en a et
les animaux les grands servidés par
exemple les dans la forêt de Rambouillet
mais personne n'en veut. Les paysans
n'en veulent pas puisque bien sûr tu
fais des maïs en bord de dur de forêt.
Les chasseurs aimerairaient bien en
tirer un peu plus. Les assureurs font la
guerre contre les les grands gibers
parce qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'accidents avec les serres et les
sangliers. Beaucoup. Et puis il y a
aussi les gens qui font pouser les tous
les forestiers parce que bien sûr quand
tu plantes des arbres les seres vont se
faire les bois dessus. Les chevills on
fait donc voilà ces pauvres animaux
personne n'en veut. Et pourtant, je
pense que
l'animal sauvage, il faut apprendre faut
apprendre à vivre avec lui. C'est
beaucoup plus compliqué de vivre avec
des loups, avec des ours, on connaît le
problème. Mais des ces biches, je pense
qu'on pourrait avoir une densité bien
plus supérieure au ces de biches, quoi
que disent les forestiers. Voilà. Et
j'aimerais qu'il des et c'est ce côté un
peu kénia que j'ai vécu où les animaux
sauvages n'ont pas peur de toi. Quel
panard de voir une antilope à 20 m qui
te regarde et qui brute tranquillement.
J'adorerais voir des ces et des biches
et j'adorerais que tous les enfants de
France puissent voir des animaux libres
comme ça. Ça c'est un cadeau, c'est très
important. Donc j'aime pas beaucoup la
chasse.
Maintenant soit la chasse à cours par
exemple, je suis contre la chasse à
cours mais c'est une chasse
traditionnelle depuis longtemps blabla
avec la tradition. Il y a des gens qui
connaissent beaucoup les animaux. La
chasse à cour dérange la forêt
énormément et c'est la façon dont c'est
fait c'est pas terrible mais ils
prennent très peu d'animaux. La chasse à
tire tire beaucoup moi dans ma région
par exemple. Je suis pas pour la chasse
à tire la chasse à cour loin de là. Mais
la chasse à cour dans la forête
d'embouillet prennent ils ont 22 animaux
chaque année.
C'est un folklore barbare.
Ouais mais peut-être d'accord mais c'est
pas mon cheval. Ils massacrent la bouche
des chevaux. Ils savent pas sauter je
Non, je crois pas tous enfin non enfin
et tu v te attends chasse à cour
laisse-moi finir chasse à cours pas
chass à cour mais ils ne ils ne prennent
que 22 animaux par an ils ont le droit
d'en prendre en point de moins. Chasse à
tir ils enent 300
chass à tire il tire il tire les
femelles alors chass à cour ne tire que
les mâles. Alors maintenant je suis
contre la chass à tire la chass à cour
ça dérange la forêt. Mais c'est je pense
que s'il y a encore des animaux sauvages
dans la forêt c'est gr ça sa cour parce
que ces gens ont protégé leur gibier
voilà il une tradition qui fait que ils
ont protégé le les animaux ils ont voilà
qui pour garder leur truc mais je suis
complètement contre je suis contre la
corriida pas rentrer là-dedans. Je
compte la corid
c'est une tradition archaïque et barbare
ou c'est les racines de la France ?
C'est un peu des deux je pense que mais
c'est c'est plus dans l'air du temps.
Mais tu sais
par rapport au aux milliards d'animaux
qui sont tués chaque année dans les
abattoirs, est-ce que voilà est-ce que
c'est on est on déteste la chass à cour
mais dans ce cas-là on devrait enf bon
je je vais pas rentrer là-dedans. C'est
on tu vois très bien ce que je veux
dire.
Je je ne suis pas un défenseur chasse
cour mais je reconnais qu'il y a une
certaine éthique et tradition dans cette
chasse qui n'est pas du tout la mienne
mais il y a un certain respect de
l'animal qui s'en doute pas c'est le
chasseur à tir voilà
la lali
est-ce que tu as envie de parler d'un
sujet avec nous
non je vrais parler de la fondation
Gloplanè
vas-y vas-y
voilà qui est qui est dirigée par des
gens voilà c'est c'est un peu une utopie
tu vois de d'avoir créé à Paris un
endroit
un petit château que nous a prêté la
ville de Paris avec 3 hectares où on est
là pour parler d'une écologie humaniste,
où on est capable de parler du
changement climatique, de parler de de
parler de de de la cuisine responsable,
de de de mettre des films qui passent
régulièrement sur l'écologie, de faire
un escape game sur le carbone, de de de
parler des réfugiés parce qu'on a fait
venir des bateaux. Bon, les réfugiés, tu
as bien compris que c'était quelque
chose qui m'a qui me passionnait. qu'on
a fait venir des bateaux. Donc c'est un
endroit très plein d'utopie où on parle
de j'aimerais de que je règne la
gentillesse, la bienveillance, on reçoit
beaucoup de gens qui viennent. C'est
gratuit,
ouvert à tous où tout le monde peut
venir parler d'écologie, parler. Il y a
des des conférences avec Pablo Serving,
Mathie, Mathieu Ricard, Mohamed Youous.
Donc voilà, c'est un endroit très
utopique où on peut on peut parler d'une
du monde de demain. Voilà, on distribue
les fameux posters qu'on a fait dans
toutes les écoles de France sur les ODD
qui sont distribués partout avec une
équipe géniale. Je suis qu'un président
de loin parce que c'est eux qui
travaillent et j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration et de tendresse pour les
gens qui qui travaillent à la fondation
et je les embrasse et j'ai il y a 350
bénévoles tout te rencontres qui
viennent
appelle-moi l'adresse.
C'est dans le bois de Boulogne. de
Carrefour de Longchamp Carrefour Voilà
Fondation GPANT il y a et on aimerait
cette cet endroit on aimerait beaucoup
le pouvoir le de multiplier à travers la
France tu vois d'avoir des comme ça voir
des endroits où les gens puissent venir
et les gens viennent en famille
piquenniquer
euh parler d'écologie d'environnement et
par exemple toi Mathieu Richard est venu
on a fait une méditation avec 1000
personnes et il se passait quelque chose
de magique tu vois et c'était assez
C'est formidable. Moi, j'adore cet
endroit et merci à la ville de Paris de
nous avoir prêté cet endroit.
Je voudrais qu'on reparle de la
convention citoyenne et du fait que
l'État a été condamné pour ce par pour
son inaction.
C'est c'est pas la convention citoyenne
qui l' condamné. Ça c'est l'affaire du
siècle. Je pardon. Je voudrais qu'on
reparle de la convention citoyenne et de
sa capacité à avoir un impact.
Alors, j'ai
on va passer on va montrer le livre qui
vient de sortir qui a fait
qui [raclement de gorge] a fait c'est
livre qui moi je pas enlever ma photo
parce que c'est pas moi qui écrit le
livre fait par les gens de ma fondation.
Voilà et c'est un j'ai été on est en
train de faire un film sur eux en ce
moment et c'est 150 personnes qui ont
été choisies au hasard par random. C'est
drôle d'ailleurs. Tu sais que con Bendit
a été choisi par hasard et quelqu'un qui
l'appelle qui dit bonjour voilà vous
êtes monsieur con Bendit. Oui,
c'est incroyable.
[rires][souffle coupé]
Donc donc c'est choisi qui beaucoup de
connaissaient rien à l'écologie et sont
sortis de là passionnés tu vois et
surtout ce qui m'a impressionné c'est la
la le d'être devenu citoyen de savoir
qu'ils avaient une responsabilité qu'ils
étaient là pour changer quelque chose et
ça ils l'ont pris à bras le corps. Et
quand par exemple, ils disent de rouler
à 120 km sur les autoroutes alors que tu
vis en province, tu vois, c'est de ou
110 km/h, tu vois, ils avaient, c'était
impossible à accepter mais c'est
eux-mêmes qui l'ont demandé. Et c'est
c'est des gens c'est des gens normaux,
c'est le français moyen, tu vois. Et
j'étais fasciné par le euh et je me
souviens, moi j'assistais à la fin où
tout le monde est tombé en pleur
d'émotion d'avoir fait quelque chose ces
propositions de Cyril Dion, Mathilde Di
Merc enfin et tous ces gens qui étaient
là en pleurant en s'embrassant. C'était
super impressionnant. Ils avaient senti
qu'ils avaient fait quelque chose
d'important dans leur vie et ça c'est
magique tu vois d'avoir donné la
possibilité à ces gens. Et c'est drôle
parce que des gens après maintenant se
sont engagés en politique, tu vois. Il y
en a qui sont qui vont devenir maire, il
y en a ça a déclenché quelque chose et
cette convention citoyenne c'est
formidable. Et d'ailleurs je te bravo à
Macron de d'avoir fait parce que pas il
faut quand même se dire que c'est quand
même lui qui a décidé de le faire. Bravo
surtout à Cyril Lion et Mathil Dimer
d'avoir convaincu Macron. Bien sûr
c'était compliqué pour lui mais au moins
il l'a fait. Voilà il y a pas il y a pas
que du mauvais hein
chez les hommes politiques. Il y a des
cop ils prennent des décisions bien sûr.
Après il a été extrêmement maladroit
quand il a parlé des amis chez du reste
mais c'est une connerie. On dit tous des
conneries dans la vie he et là il a été
il a déconné.
Question d'internet
quitte de son influence à l'étranger.
Est-ce que est-ce que Yan Artus Bertrand
il est influent à l'étranger ? Est-ce
qu'on l'écoute ? Alors, je vais te dire
euh
d'abord euh quand tu as la chance de
faire des films comme moi et que tes
films sont distribués à l'étranger, un
film comme Home par exemple, par chance
hein, parce que on a avec Luc Besson, on
a on a vraiment trouvé parce que le
cinéma c'est quand même un truc d'argent
quoi. Tu es des producteurs qui ont qui
font un film et après le film sort, il y
a les droits et donc le film sont jamais
libre de droit, tu vois. Et là, on avec
Luc Besson, j'ai convaincu Luc de
trouver un Messen pour payer Home et ce
qui fait que le film a été une histoire
incroyable. Home a été vu par après 600
millions de personnes dans le monde. Euh
et que par exemple quand tu passes en
prime time sur la télévision chinoise,
tu as 2500 millions00 de personnes qui
voient ton film. À tel point qu'en
Chine, il y a une association qui
s'appelle Home. Ils ont fait des DVD
puisque comme c'est libre de droit, ils
le font. Et les DVD, il les
présentaient. Alors, je sais plus si ça
marche encore beaucoup. Moi, j'ai été en
un en Chine a quelques années. Il
m'avait il avait tous un groupement
d'associations. Des milliers de gens ont
le DVD de home chez eux et allaiit le
présenter dans les écoles, allit le
présenter dans les mariages, dans la
rue. Extraordinaire quoi. Donc je dois
pas avoir une grande Mais quand tu fais
des films et que tu es vu par des par
des millions de personnes, tu as une
responsabilité de faire les choses bien.
Dire. Je me souviens quand j'avais été
au César, j'avais remis un prix
et j'avais dit, j'avais un petit
discours écolo en mettant un prix, un
silence de mort. Tu vois vraiment
qu'est-ce qui nous fait chier il y a ça
10 ans et je leur avais dit voilà vous
vous êtes vu, vous êtes vu par des
millions de personnes, vous avez une
responsabilité de parler d'écologie et
d'environnement. Je pense que le cinéma
te permet d'avoir de d'envoyer des
messages comme ça à travers le monde et
voilà et que aujourd'hui le cinéma est
en train de le faire. J'étais hier avec
le CNC, tu vois, où il me demandait de
réfléchir. Ils ont ils travaillent avec
Jeanco afin que maintenant il va avoir
une quand tu vas voir les aides du CNC,
donc pour faire ton cinéma, tu pouras
respecter certaines règles écologiques
et c'est vachement bien.
On arrive à la à la fin de notre
interview.
Ouf ! Ouf ! [rires]
Tu veux continuer encore ?
Non mais je je c'est avec plaisir de
parler avec vous. C'est je les gens vont
en avoir marre. Est-ce que Non, c'est
pas vrai parce que la ils sont tous bien
actifs, ils sont très contents
d'ailleurs.
D'accord.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres
? Ça marche toujours quand tu parles
d'amour. Tu sais, je pense que on a tous
en nous cette envie de
d'avoir un monde meilleur, tu vois, et
de de partager et de
d'imaginer un monde, tu vois, de de avec
un happy end, tu vois. Moi, j'aime bien
le j'aime bien le cinéma quand ça finit
bien, tu vois. Et et là, on peut y
mettre on est sur une route où il y a
mauvaise fin, on a tous envie d'avoir
une une fin heureuse et et donc ensemble
euh de tous imaginer qu'on peut y
arriver ensemble euh ça me plaît parce
qu'on va pas y arriver tout seul. C'est
pas toi qui va y arriver et moi tout
seul. On va tous y arriver ensemble. Et
je pense qu'on a tous des enfants, on a
tous des gens qu'on aime et on a tous
envie d'avoir un monde meilleur demain.
Et cette ce discours de fin du monde
annoncé, c'est quelque part
insupportable et on peut tous se battre
contre ça.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres et trois
documentaires à conseiller à notre
communauté ?
Alors euh
il y a un livre qui s'appelle La
supplication
qui est un des livres que je préfère qui
était écrit par le prix Nobel euh russe
de littérature, je vous dirais je veux
pas même pas prononcer son nom parce que
elle a un pronom imprononçable euh Aovic
quelque chose. Je suis très mauvais dans
les noms et c'est un livre formidable
sur
faut dire le nom. Vas-y cherche sur
internet took sur l'ordinateur Nobel
laication. Voilà, il se sûrement des
gens qui vont
on demande à la communauté d'aller
chercher.
S'il vous plaît les gars et c'est une
c'est peut-être pour moi la
une des plus grande encore une femme
encore qui a écrit un livre s'appelle
cercueil de plombs sur la la guerre la
guerre d'Afghanistan qui a écrit des
livres sur les femmes et la guerre.
C'est vraiment une le prix Nobel quand
même donc c'est une femme extraordinaire
que j'avais rencontré en en où est-ce
qu'elle vit déjà ?
J'ai un trou, c'est pas grave, dans une
étabe. Formidable, un pays dictateur,
dites-moi un pays avec un dictateur.
Bah de quelle année ?
Quoi ? Maintenant, en ce moment là,
maintenant euh
un des trois pays. Bah, vas-y. Alors,
non, on a l' on a vraiment l'air de con
devant des milliers centaines de
milliers. Je
dire Yanukovic mais non
non mais c'est bon, elle comment
s'appelle ce vit, elle vit à
Biélorussie.
Biélorussie. Voilà, elle vit en
Biélorussie. Et euh et c'est et c'est
J'ai une histoire extraordinaire à
raconter.
Alors, on a le nom si tu veux.
Vas-y.
Zvet, attends. Zvetlana Alexier
Alexevic.
Voilà. Voilà.
Tu vois que le nom est pas facile à
dire. Et et donc c'est un livre, elle a
c'est une femme extraordinaire. J'ai lu
lu lu son bouquin
et elle a écrit beaucoup de livres. Et
un jour, je suis invité à Minsk faire
une projection de Elle a eu le prix
Nobel et quand j'arrive à l'aéroport,
c'est elle qui m'a créé un bouquet de
fleurs. Là, je savais pas que c'est elle
qui m'avait et tout l'argent du prix
Nobel, elle fait venir des gens des gens
qu'elle aime dans son pays pour par pour
parler de de de démocratie et de
liberté. Et donc, on a fait deux
projections de human formidable. Donc ça
voilà, ça c'est un auteur formidable, la
supplication c'est un des livres mes
préférés. Après je dis bon, j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup de livres sur
l'écologie en vivant en ce moment. Euh
il y a toi tu le collapse de
collapse qui un film sur le qui qui
raconte. Je suis très mauvais. Je je je
tous [rires]
jeis fatigué ce soir. Mais quoi qu'il a
soit collapse qui est un bouquin
formidable
sur le l'île de pâqu toi comment les
civilisations décident de vivre ou pas.
Les bouquins de Jeanco bien sûr. Et il y
a un un auteur que j'aime beaucoup de
Morrison qui est le retour qui est un
auteur américain, un livre que je lis
régulièrement en roman parce que je lis
très très peu de romans en fin de
compte. J'ai beaucoup de d'essais.
Voilà. Euh qu'est-ce que je suis en
train de lire en ce moment ? Je suis en
train de lire qu'est-ce que je suis en
train de lire ? Je suis en train de lire
un bouquin sur John Mur qui est un le
gars qui a fondé le Sara Club aux
États-Unis parce qu'il faut savoir
qu'aux États-Unis les grandes réserves,
les premières réserves euh nationales
ont été créées aux États-Unis et il y a
un bouquin formidable. J'aurais pu être
j'aurais pu être milliardaire et je suis
devenu vagabond. C'est je suis en train
de lire ce livre qui est passionnant.
Voilà, je lis énormément de livres sur
l'écologie et on est il en paraît
tellement voilà peut-être peut-être ça
ça c'est pas un mauvais bouquin aussi.
Voilà.
Est-ce que tu as Est-ce que tu as un
conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Mais ça c'est des questions conc que tu
me racontes mon ch
c'est alors c'est c'est une question
qu'on pose oui mais qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire c'est un conseil fénération
moi je pense que
c'est
va au bout de tes rêves et saisis ta
chance tu as envie de faire quelque
chose essaye. Vénération c'est d'essayer
d'essayer d'essayer. Tu vas peut-être
pas y arriver mais essaye. C'est
tellement important. Voilà. et et va au
bout de tes rêves et et ne passe pas à
côté de ta chance. Si tu as la chance
est là, tu laisses hésiter. Il va
prendre des risques, peut-être te casser
la gueule mais euh
tu peux y arriver. Et surtout si tu
essayes pas euh si tu essayes pas toute
ta vie, tu dis "Merde, j'aurais dû
essayer." Voilà, tu as une envie, va au
bout va au bout de tes rêves. Ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose. Moi ça a marché
avec moi. Donc peut-être ça peut marcher
pour vous aussi. Artus Bertrand, merci.
[musique]